i just opened it there we go sometimes
obs freezes on us but we're good how's
it going everybody so uh you know we're
all contemplating and you know the the
catastrophe in afghanistan the loss of
american lives the americans that are
trapped there and you know biden said
like nobody saw this coming we didn't
think it was going to happen and then a
phone call gets leaked where he knew it
was happening and didn't provide air
support after the president of
afghanistan asked him to where he had
previously just a few weeks earlier
quietly pulled american troops out of
bagram air force base in the dead of
night shutting off the electricity and
not telling anybody let alone the afghan
allies so uh when you see this and you
know that
we i mean it should have been obvious
that they were asking for help but the
president of afghanistan before kabul
fell to the taliban said we need air
support and biden was like just tell
everybody it's all fine
and uh he knew it was collapsing and
they knew weeks in advance the taliban
was rapidly approaching they knew weeks
in advance that
everyone in the world saw this happening
and he just wanted to change the
perception
says to me that uh they didn't care
or this was the plan the whole time so
we'll talk about that i i did talk about
it earlier on one of my segments but we
got the crew here we'll talk about that
we got a bunch of other stories we've
got uh you know curfew just been enacted
in in new orleans the hurricane hit is
pretty bad and uh joe rogan you got
coven
but i don't think it's that big of a
deal you know uh we'll talk about all
that stuff you know he did a video on
instagram appears to be fine and the
media of course is going nuts talking
about horse d warmer
we'll talk about that uh we are being
rejoined finally at last i'm back hi
jack murphy hey good to be here tim
lydia yeah it's been too long happy to
be here i'm jack murphy
ready to get started on our every other
wednesday cycle 91 9 15 9 29 so forth
and so on thank you you were gone for a
while jack i was man we had summer tour
we had travel we had all kinds of stuff
going on but we were back to work i you
know i heard i got nothing to do with
you i got dms i got dm's ian looks
lonely he's sad he needs uncle jack life
is hard yeah and i'm back thanks for
having me guys happy to be here we were
all concerned because he was like
sleeping one day and didn't get out and
i i went to his door and knocked an
answer and then i put my hair to the
door and i heard him saying yeah jack
repeating it
he was following my twitter feed at jack
murphy live he was also watching my
videos i had jack murphy live on youtube
because really good videos designs
soccer accounts yeah i comment a lot you
do actually i can tell each time thank
you how was the grand canyon man the
grand canyon was big it was beautiful it
was amazing it was stunning
vacuum like it was sucking you into it
when you got near it it really did it
really did i didn't want to leave i went
to grand canyon bryce and zion did not
want to leave each place i felt sad i
felt mourning leaving each place because
they're so profound in their just
brilliance and and enormity really puts
your life in perspective
that's why we're here that's why we're
here to put your life in perspective our
lives the perspective let's do it
iacrossly hey ian crossland in the house
jack murphy live yes happy to be here
i'm loving it i'm so glad jack is back
it's gonna be a great wednesday as it
always is with jack looking forward to
it before we get started head over to
timcast.com and become a member and you
get access to exclusive members only
segments from the show as well as an ad
free experience we just hired another
journalist so we're just
hiring more and more journalists and i
just got to tell you this is because
we want to make good journalism um the
news industry is not a particularly
lucrative lucrative interest industry
the opinion industry however is a
booming and thanks to all the members
who like this show and the member
segments we are able to hire more
journalists and that's kind of how it
works you know dude you definitely hired
a bunch of people because i haven't been
here in about six weeks i walked in the
house people are like accosting me
gently approaching me with video cameras
multiple angles there's like paparazzi
there's guys at workstations there's
screens up on the walls people are
grinding editing producing it's a
beehive of activity in here tim we're
taking over you really are manchester
united it's all thanks to you as members
at timecast.com uh don't forget to like
this video subscribe to the channel
share the show is the most powerful
thing you can do if you really like it
let's read this news you may have heard
wow amazing from timcast.com biden urged
afghan president to change the
perception of taliban's imminent victory
reuters reports new details are emerging
from the final phone call between u.s
president biden and the afghan president
ashraf ghani with reports claiming biden
urged the foreign leader to change
perceptions that the taliban was winning
the war the call took place on july 23rd
on august 15th ghani fled the
presidential palace and the taliban
entered kabul since then tens of
thousands of desperate afghans have fled
and 13 u.s troops have lost their lives
scores of afghan civilians
here's a quote from biden i need not
tell you the perception around the world
and in parts of afghanistan i believe is
that things are not going well in terms
of the fight against the taliban
and there is a need whether it's true or
not there is a need to project a
different picture
we will provide we will continue to
provide close air support if we know
what the plan is biden told ghani you
clearly have the best military you have
300 000 well-armed forces versus 70 to
80 000 and they're clearly capable of
fighting well
so it sounds like a lot of lies coming
out of the white house in these past few
weeks so we didn't know what was going
to happen they knew it was happening
then
on july 1st they abandoned bagram air
force base that's been like the the
center piece of this big story in the in
the scandal as to what went down because
they didn't just hand off
they didn't here's what should have
happened in my opinion and you know
maybe i'm wrong cause i'm not a military
guy the administration could have said
all right it's currently may by july 1st
we will leave which gives us a month to
get in some afghan security forces
afghan national you know army to start
replacing the people who run the air
force base so that you can properly take
it over have the logistics and then
start dealing with the taliban should
they come in after we leave
instead
in the middle of the night on july 1st
they turned the lights off cut the power
and fled without telling anybody and
civilian looters busted in and then when
the afghan army found out they went in
and tried and secured it and arrested
people but you got to imagine
by july 23rd about three weeks before
the fall of kabul when the president of
afghanistan is like yo biden we need
some air support they already abandoned
the air force base without telling them
and brad is like yeah we'll provide you
with their support just keep telling
everybody you're winning
so to me
kind of sounds like the plan man
it's indeed the plan but you gotta
wonder that's the plan from biden's
perspective you gotta wonder how where
the lies start right does the lie start
all the way down with yeah we just
trained these four new recruits to the
afghan security forces and they're great
they're doing a great job and those lies
just multiply and add up and build up
and add up and build up to where joe
biden is like hey we really have 300 000
troops there they're really going to be
helpful for you you're fine 300 000
versus 80 000 it's fine i mean that's
the intel that he's getting look i am
not a joe biden fan i'm not defending
joe biden the guy needs to be put into a
nice comfortable rocking chair with a
blanket over his lap
nice book in his lap if he can read and
a cup of tea in the whole thing
so let me pat him on the head every once
in a while tuck him in wipe his nose
sponge baths
well
i'm not volunteering or sticking that on
anybody
but like it's it's it's a compounding
lie after lie after lie after lie after
lie after lie after lie after lie
and you know really the president is a
guy that's up there playing risk you
know he's got the board he's got the
pieces he can only depend on the
information that he's been giving and
it's from my perspective it seems like
the entire military industrial complex
is just filled with liars scoundrels and
thieves who are not doing their job but
they want war right that's what i'm
saying so i
you are you saying that you know biden
wanted to withdraw and so they it's the
military industrial complex that screwed
it up and gave him bad info or whatever
i think that that when you've got biden
and his team and the wokefied apparatus
that's now taking over everything their
focus is always on the wrong thing
they're always focused and they're
putting their attention on the wrong
thing so whenever they take action it's
the wrong action because their focus is
on wokeness it's on you know making sure
that the uh what my words i can't say
over here making sure that the army is
diverse enough making sure that they're
dealing with white rage and these things
and and they're not making sure that the
facts and the information that they're
getting are accurate and so they're just
taking these things at face value
basically you can't take anything at
face value anymore nothing but is it
lies or is it collapse right so i'll put
the rot
imagine the military is a bunch of you
know you ever see that meme where it's
like two people standing on a cliff and
it's like a beautiful city and they're
hugging and then holding the cliff up as
a bunch of soldiers that are like
bleeding and one guy's pointing a gun
and they're holding it up yeah it's
making a point about how this comfort
this luxury is based on it so imagine
that support structure of all of these
dudes holding up society not that i'm a
fan of the afghan war by stretch of the
imagination but you start
corrupting and rotting those those
support beams and they start just
writhing and falling and collapsing and
then eventually the structure loses
support the whole thing falls down so is
it is it really lies or is it here's the
way i see it um and i'll and i'll do a
side note here we got a video remote we
got a strike on tick tock
because i'm tick tock on tick tock
because i said in a video
it's clear biden is in charge
that there are no there are no adults in
the room and that when biden's talking
in his meetings and says stuff people
just go along with whatever he says and
don't challenge him he's got sycophants
and bureaucrats who don't want to stick
their neck out and biden's clearly not
with it and so we got to strike for that
but but i stand by that i think what's
happening is you've got you know kamala
millie you know uh
other people right the national security
advisor you've got gensake and they're
like i'm not saying anything it's like
joe biden walks in he sits down and we
heard him say trinidad a shop at a
pressure on tv what do you think he's
saying in private right when he's
sitting there and they're all sitting
around him and he's like
cowboy commercial but then
do it and they're like uh
whatever you say joe and they just walk
out shrugging we know one of the things
he says in private which is uh hey
leader of afghanistan lie to the world
yeah
i mean it was when he said whether it's
true or not yes whether it's true or not
just lie lie if you have to but true
people do you wish anything would have
gone differently in afghanistan yeah i
wish the president wouldn't have fled
you know
this whole like crap
it's like they didn't want to hurt the
taliban's feelings we had an out date by
september 1st or august 31st what you do
as a military if you're not prepared to
leave a war that you're winning
you extend the deadline were we winning
yeah we were dominating that country we
controlled the country we had a total
air support we had we had i don't know
logistics we had total
opportunity to withdraw safely
everything over time
and they just chose to surrender biden
surrendered when we were winning the war
he didn't just issue a white piece and
walk away he surrendered our equipment
i actually agree i agree with i i think
so i agree yes in in that in that sense
i would say
there when i say i don't know if we were
winning it's like it's 20 years in
attrition and soldiers are dying every
year and there were some serious attacks
the past few years and i'm like i don't
know if it's winning if we're in a
country we don't need to be in to
colonize our nation build from people
who don't want us to be there i don't
know what we're trying to win other than
invading this country but from what
you're saying in that in that sense yes
we not only did we have control of the
country but we did have the afghan
national army and i think this story is
the perfect example of how
it all broke it's the it's it's amazing
it's the breaking point it's almost like
there really was a system in place not a
good one i still believe there would
have been chaos and conflict but it's
like joe biden the administration made
sure to find the one support beam they
could strip out to make sure it all went
smack down and collapse on the way out
they they pulled logistics and air
support they abandoned the air force
base around kabul or bagram near kabul
they couldn't do evacuations it really
felt like of all of the things they
could have done they did quite possibly
the worst thing i guess the worst thing
would be to bomb your own you know like
the civilians okay so in the sense of
strategy for the withdrawal this was the
worst thing they could have done yes a
premature surrender in getting the
withdrawal executed sure there was a lot
of tactical and operational errors for
sure but like we were losing that war
the minute we started well it's not a
war with a with a valuable goal i don't
think i think it was a pointless
endeavor but we were dominating in force
we we were winning the forces were we
really though because the whole point i
guess well not the whole point but one
of the points of being there was to
build up this army that was going to be
able to defend afghanistan from all
these other bad guys and in the very
first
possible moment
where they were there to do the job that
they were trained for they didn't just
do the job poorly
they just said
just kidding we're not even doing it oh
but there's so i i i agree disagree uh i
think they certainly did a poor job but
there's a video of afghan uh commandos
fighting back defending you know
territory from the taliban and they run
out of ammo and the taliban comes in so
they drop their guns and taliman
executes them there's video of this
happening they post the taliban wants to
post their victories right you have joe
biden abandoning bagram in the dead of
night
without telling them right so it's like
if you've got
you're you're a country that's been
built up by 20 years of occupation
america comes in
they build up this whole apparatus in
afghanistan
and they say it's our air base here's
what we're going to do here's the
logistic here's the contractors and
you're like okay i guess and there's no
handoff of power and then all of a
sudden one one day
the taliban is storming in because
you're pulling out and you're like all
right let's go where's our air force
nobody's there what do you mean nobody's
there right they they they did fight and
not every single one
we had afghan national army defending
the kabul airport and i think you know
initially this was my mistake too when
biden came out and said you have afghan
uh you know uh security forces unwilling
or he said why should we send the next
generation of americans to fight a war
the afghans are not willing to fight
themselves and i was like it's a good
point and then i started reading the
reports i started reading the the the
the experts reading the timeline of
events and i was like yo that's brutal
some of these guys did fight really
really hard but biden pulled support on
july 1st sure sure so so i'm sure some
of them were definitely you know died in
the world true believers afghan army
fighters wanting to defend themselves
and their country from the taliban but
if you take it a couple of other data
points one the pew study that says 99 of
afghanistan citizens want to have sharia
law enacted and you contrast that with
our efforts to to take afghanistan into
modernity by teaching them gender
studies
by trying to actually you know encourage
homosexuality and all these things and
and women's rights
the culture the culture
culture clash
thinking of that cohen brothers movie
culture crush uh the culture clash uh
there was irreconcilable and and the
civilizational clash was irreconcilable
and though and there's one last point on
this the whole american military machine
is supported by this enormous logistics
infrastructure right air support
weapons and development research and
development supply chains manufacturing
all these things
and they trained apparently and i'm not
an expert but i do talk to many uh they
train the afghan army to operate the
same way that the united states military
does which requires this gigantic
infrastructure behind it right and so
the minute you pull that infrastructure
out well then of course it's it's stupid
it's like it's like it's like giving the
whole afghan army a bunch of teslas to
drive and then then taking away the
electricity
did you see that that's actually a
really good metaphor there's a photo i
don't know if it's real or not but it's
a taliban guy pointing a gun a bunch of
civilians who are like shocked and
scared and they're standing up against a
wall of like the un security goals or
whatever i don't know if that's true
because it's awfully convenient but i'm
like it was a convincing photo
nonetheless and it was like here's our
sustainability goals you know or
whatever the plan they got the website
taliban's all about the memes these days
i hear posting memes they're killing it
on twitter dude killing it on twitter
now hold on it's not all uh bad news
because we have uh we have this story
from politico uh we have another story
too uh apparently mark milley says it's
possible the u.s will work with the town
again oh because of isis k cool so uh so
we have that and then we also we also
have the bud administration is now
considering giving the taliban cash aid
if they uphold their international
obligations so it seems like biden's
strategy was like well
we can pay to have people there on the
ground securing the country indefinitely
or we can pay the taliban to just do
whatever as long as they do the things
we like we know how that plays out you
give the taliban cash you encourage all
the bad things they're doing because
then they're like we'll keep doing bad
things unless you give us more money
then you give them money the bad things
go down for a few months and they start
coming back and they say well maybe you
got to give us more money it's like that
trope where the guy like walks the the
private detective walks in and he's like
i need information and then he's like
you know maybe i need a little cash and
then he hands him money and the guy goes
maybe i need a little bit more and he
keeps milking as much as you can yeah
you can't do that doesn't work well when
you lose a war the loser always pays
period we lost a war therefore we pay
none of that surprises me
when you lose a war you pay money ask
england or sorry even even if you help
somebody win a war they still pay well
you can also end a war with what's
called a white peace which is where
nobody wins and nobody loses it's just
the war just stops and that's probably
what should have happened but they
surrendered
that's a different form of ending a war
that's when you give them money
i think all this comes back to our
original question that we formulated a
while back dumb or diabolical
dumb or diabolical i'm leaning dumb here
they're gonna work with the taliban and
give them cash i don't know if that's
that's i mean it could be dumb
antibiotics i just mean the entire the
entire thing is dumb the entire every
decision to go in going all the way back
to george w bush's decision to go in
there his announcement in the second
inaugural address where he says that the
american foreign policy goal is to end
tyranny across the world what that was a
radical transformation of american
foreign policy that was doomed from the
start its representative a progressive
ideology and it has now played out over
20 years where along the way we tried to
gender studies them up in the whole
thing to make them peaceful and modern
just like us and it failed it failed to
fail to fail it's dumb dumb dumb dumb
dumb all down the way what did what did
we do back in uh let me make sure i have
the year right what was the the cold war
era in afghanistan the 1970s yeah what
who who was it that was uh being trained
and armed in the 1970s in afghanistan by
the united states some bad guys that
came later to blow us up yeah they call
them the movie
oh the mujahideen yeah yeah and the us
armed and trained them so they would
fight against the soviets and drive the
the soviet union out and they did and
then later on broke off to form al-qaeda
on the taliban that al-qaeda attacks us
and then taliban takes over afghanistan
and the u.s goes oh oh no now we have to
evade iraq
i guess because saddam hussein is bad
and you know that whole thing's going on
so then we did that of course we went to
afghanistan first and so i look at this
and i'm wondering jack are they really
dumb
or is iran about to get a whole lot of
weapons high grade advanced american
weaponry because afghanistan can't
maintain their own economy already we're
seeing videos and photos of people
lining up outside of banks by the
hundreds because the economy just
stopped there's no central banker
anymore not like i like central banking
but the people who ran that place are
gone you think the taliban keep the
power on no but i'll tell you what they
can do they can call their buddies over
in iran and say we need infrastructure
help now and iran will be like we see
you've got some pretty uh blackhawks
over there so what happens real quick in
10 15 or 20 years
when you've got a new isis armed with
advanced american weaponry and they're
causing problems and the older
generation is is retiring there or or
many are passing on you know we are all
you know we're going to be in our 50s
and 60s and the young generation not
remembering any of what happened says oh
no these evil people overseas are are
are you know violent and oppressive we
should stop them and the us goes uh oh
no look at all the weapons and all the
terror we have to stop them so the u.s
arms and funds the mujahideen they
become the al-qaeda of the taliban
justification for our wars in the middle
east once again and are we on that same
track probably because we're stupid we
don't understand anything that's going
on over there we don't any understand
any of the the historical tribal
differences we don't understand all of
it now but you brought up a lot of
points just give me just a little bit of
space to get to them i have talked to a
number of experts military experts us
special forces captains and pilots that
have flown this type of equipment that
is there on the ground who operated in
theater logisticians whose job it was to
support the aircraft in the in the
helicopters that are on the ground in
afghanistan and to a man each single one
of them told me the same thing one
any of the technology that we gave the
afghanistan army was old old stuff it
was not the latest and greatest none of
it we didn't give them the highest
latest and greatest weapon weaponry
systems and they weren't even the latest
and greatest blackhawk versions
two that china and iran have both had
access to this technology since the 80s
three that it will be impossible to
sustain and maintain this hardware in
that desert without the massive
logistical support that comes with the
united states military
so
and again i get tons of pushback on this
on twitter i don't know about any of
this stuff i'm literally talking to
people that were in theater in field who
know this equipment and know how it
works and this is what they have told me
people people often respond to us saying
that iran still uses you know captured
planes from the 70s they do because now
this is in the comparison again i've had
the same argument and i researched the
same thing the difference between iran
and afghanistan are vast iran has is a
fully formed civilization of thousands
of years
they have their own domestic commercial
aviation industry they make planes and
engines and stuff
afghanistan doesn't even have
electricity okay what differentiator is
to the west of afghanistan
now to that point as far as i understand
it and i'm not an expert so if i'm wrong
i apologize people tell me
iran shia
afghanistan sunni
how are they how they're they're they're
natural-born enemies why are they
supporting each other are they
supporting each other
i don't know so all these arguments that
i'm hearing about iran's going to help
afghanistan and we're giving them all
this equipment and whatever upon further
investigation not all of that holds up
i mean well i i don't i wouldn't say
that doesn't hold up good argument and
obviously look we're a bunch of guys on
the internet acting you're talking about
this great war and i'm sure there's some
like you know e4 or whatever was like he
knows him so much more than we did i'm
sure but i've talked to the guys that
actually know who are in the field that
fly the things that fly the things in
afghanistan have been there and done it
and supported it it takes in order to do
a hardware overhaul on a blackhawk it
takes a year to disassemble it
before it takes two years to put it back
together oh yeah yeah and that is just
to support it from regular flight
operations and i see they're doing
military parades and there and you know
guys by the way that the blackhawk image
of the guy hanging from it he wasn't
hanging he was in a harness and he was
waving to everybody yeah okay they were
flaunting it they weren't killing
anybody but the point is they're just
joyriding this stuff around which means
it's gonna degrade even more quickly but
they don't care because they beat us
without any of that crap in the first
place you know why because they have
time and they have mountains no no no
i'm pretty sure they had f-15s and
nuclear weapons right you know joe biden
said you'd have to have that to defeat
the us clearly they did and biden's just
keeping it a secret from us because if
we found out the taliban had knowns we'd
be real scared right indeed or they're
just mountain people with guns mountain
people with guns which is exactly what i
want to be here in the united states and
i had a friend joke that appalachia will
be the graveyard of empires yeah here in
the united states wow that's a cool
right the graveyard of empires in
appalachia it's like like you know so i
was i was watching this i was reading
something about why afghanistan is just
a terrible location and it's because
there's people who who grow up there who
live there who live in the mountains and
s
subsist on mountain life and we try to
go in and that's the high ground it's
very difficult to occupy for people i
mean it's the altitude it's the
breathing and so there's not a lot there
it's rocky and it's just hard to hard to
hold no no great empire's been able to
do it
so i wonder if that you know then
translates to to appalachia it does
indeed it does indeed and i was just
watching the patriot the other night and
it's a historical significance aside
uh powerful movie but there's a great
line in there where mel gibson's like
you know i taught you every back trail
and cave and hideout in this region and
that's what we're gonna do and that's
how we're gonna use it and that's what
i've always been taught about the
american revolution is that we
ultimately won mostly because we knew
the train and we could act in a gorilla
fashion etc but look i think that's a
myth actually that that is why we won
yeah i think it wasn't because we stood
up in front of the british and just shot
more musket balls no it was because the
french intervened and britain was
strained and then
i mean the revolution went on for 20
years you know the formal declaration
happened sometime after there was
already revolution in rebellion yeah
and and there was shooting and the
british empire was finally like we can't
do this anymore but uh i do think the
grill tax obviously did play a role for
sure but i think it's overstated i was
reading something about it yeah and they
were like
i think it's understated how much the
french intervening was like i think the
french wiped out the british navy at
some point it did and they showed up
there at the end and it was really
helpful but uh to just to finish this
one thought um look if you're going to
colonize
a country
you can't just send a governor and some
army guys and hope that you're going to
change the nature of the country
you have to send families
you have to send settlers you have to
send people to build cities and create
culture and art and commerce and all
these things which is why actually
we in the united states
gained our independence is because they
had to send actual humans and families
and people to settle the united states
it wasn't just a colony in the caribbean
or in africa where we could just send a
governor and some troops and just
extract the resources that we wanted
from those countries we had to actually
send human beings to come live here and
have their lives here which is why in a
way it was so successful
that it was such a civilization that we
were like you know stories that's it to
england that you need stories for the
people the people who are who are
growing up in afghanistan don't have any
national unity the story that they're
told that the kids growing up is the
americans invaded and took over and now
we live under their rule what great
story so you know when i'm a kid and i'm
growing up i see that photo of iwo jima
and they're raising the flag and you
know never forget and all of these
things these things meant to inspire and
tell kids that's what you want to be
like that's what you aspire to be
what do they have in afghanistan if
they're not if they're you're growing up
and you're like we were conquered
right what what what so
they were celebrating with the taliban
well they didn't that's not the story
they told them what they told them was
that
empires alexander is great the russians
the americans they all come here and
they all lose son son we're just waiting
them out
yeah
and i don't want to use this cliche
because it's so cliched and everybody
uses it but they're like son they got
watches we got time oh yeah yeah that's
the thing if you're going to colonize
mountains a desert mountain then you
need to import food and that's going to
cost you trillions and trillions of
dollars you need to import water that's
another trip but for 80 years you got to
fund that thing it's going to be an 80
year project three centuries if you want
that to happen the the fundamental error
here is that we in our progressive era
politics and foreign policy and
modernity and all these things that we
think we can change everyone around the
world if they could just listen to us
and learn our ways they will improve and
change and whatever and our arrogance
led us to believe that not only were we
going to just go to like a country that
was like a step below us and just kind
of bring them up to where we were no we
were going to go to the most bass
ackwards place in the entire world with
a civilization more antithetical to ours
than any other in existence
and try to bring them up to 2021
wokeness
is that is the height of folly i i i'll
tell you what i think
what country is uh uh uh
to the west of afghanistan we mentioned
it but i'm asking again oh my god i
don't know there's there's like there's
pakistan and iran and iraq and there and
china is over they're all over there
somewhere to the west of afghanistan why
are you putting me on this side
directly west of afghanistan is iran
okay there we go do you know what
country is directly east of iraq
iran iran and so when you look at what
john bolton's been saying that we will
be celebrating victory in tehran by this
time next year a couple of years ago it
sounds to me like the purpose of
afghanistan is not
to to create a nation necessarily but to
create a stronghold where we can supply
troops and have military infrastructure
because they wanted to invade iran oh
well that's absolutely true that was all
part of the neocon domino's falling
theory that they put forth
after
after we decided to invade okay that's
the part that people forget i believe is
that we decided to invade afghanistan
and then iraq before wolfowitz and the
neocons had fully formulated their
spreading democracy concept i believe
that the spreading democracy concept
came after the urge to invade
afghanistan and iraq but this is me
going back 20 years and trying to
remember the news report news reports at
the time i was in grad school so we were
talking about this quite a bit
and uh i just remember wolfowitz and the
neocons formulating the spreading of
democracy in the domino's falling theory
after it was already determined by
bush's rhetoric going
he would he would do this word smash
where he would go uh iraq uh al qaeda
911 afghanistan saddam hussein iraq
weapons of mass destruction afghanistan
iraq saddam hussein terror terror and he
would just he would just mash all those
words up together without any logical
coherence but he would just say them
together in a rhythm in such a way that
everyone began to associate
all those concepts together al qaeda
afghanistan saddam hussein weapons of
mass destruction iraq ah 9 11. ah more
of this is going to happen ah we have to
defend ourselves that was that was the
the banging of the war drums at that
time and i believe that the academic
infrastructure for all this the
wolfowitz led neocon theory abdominal
falling and such
my my memory could be wrong and i was
younger then for sure uh was that that
came after afterwards and became the
justification for this prolonged
experience that we had there that of
course the military-industrial complex
gets behind they're like yeah we can
sell more bombs you know i'm really
really impressed by you've got to give
it to united states the power and the
prowess of their armed forces in being
able to stage an invasion of a country
less than a month after the terror
attack that happened which was the
reason for that attack so we invaded
afghanistan in october of 2001 october
7th 2001. so that means 9 11.
9 11 happens
george w bush says we know who did it
he reached out to the taliban and says
hand over osama bin laden they said give
us proof he says we don't need proof we
know he's guilty i'm paraphrasing but
that's like near near accurate quote
yeah and then in less than a month the
u.s had the resources and the strategic
positions to invade a country i mean
that is
that is wow
they've been at this for for decades and
decades are you insinuating that 911 was
an inside job meant to determine to set
us on some foreign policy excursion no i
think george w bush wanted to invade
afghanistan no matter what happened and
after 9 11 happened he was like
well afghanistan or iraq i would i would
actually iraq was later no i had it
in the 90s so i remember their arguments
back then because i'm a little bit older
than you guys and i remember them saying
like all this is about george bush
avenging his daddy and so maybe maybe in
his mind and i don't know i'm totally
speculating i know people who know this
so maybe i should just ask them but uh
you know maybe when he got in office
he's like we got to fix this thing in
iraq um and then 911 happened and it was
like oh we'll do this then we'll do that
i'm saying they wanted to invade already
like they they they were they were they
just wanted we had we had uh
they they talked about it we had in the
invasion in the 90s they wanted to go in
the neocons wanted they wanted
to invade and i was saying that we we
were very quick in our like what i mean
to say is we we we waited no time right
we didn't say like let's have
international hearings let's let's let's
get a third a third nation involved to
to make demands of the taliban let's put
international pressure it was like less
than a month it was like dude send in
the truth we didn't go after bin laden
we set up a nation building
yeah part of the project we did but then
we let him go and let him go to practice
but uh i'll push back on one thing you
said there uh they definitely formed an
international coalition they definitely
brought in other countries there
definitely was a huge coalition of
countries that went in i don't care i
don't mean for invasion i mean
hey how about before we invade a country
we have council hearings you know we we
make demands we sanction like it's
really interesting that the taliban said
give us proof bush said we don't need
proof we know he's guilty and then we're
going to war in less than a month it's
like yo yo halliburton is ready let's
get those
you know what's funny uh if you think
about the timeline actually uh from
1991 until
september 11th that's the period in time
that i call the pox americana that is
when we were cashing the peace dividend
at the end of the cold war there wasn't
any obvious international like hegemon
that could like was like challenging us
anywhere the soviet union had fallen we
had gotten so comfortable actually that
we had turned our foreign policy
attention to the western hemisphere we
were like engaging with latin america
we're going to build a free trade area
of the americas all this stuff there
wasn't any real war or military conflict
or clearly find an enemy at all
whatsoever from 91
until 2001. so it is a reasonable
presumption to make that in that
intervening 10 years
all the military industrial complex guys
were like oh we got to get something
here we got to get something going we
got to get something what's it going to
be what's it going to be what's it going
to be and then iraq and then iraq and
and i mean we did have saddam hussein in
the iraq thing well we did but you know
he was a boogeyman but those are teeny
tiny those are teeny tiny little things
they wanted a 20-year guaranteed no-bid
contract resource extraction the whole
thing yeah yeah i'm trying to remember
um what year was uh bush's sectional
second second election was that two
thousand two or four was 2004. yeah 2000
he got elected 2004 was realized 2004.
yeah so by the time he makes that second
inaugural and the the goal of america is
to end tyranny around the world we had
already been way way involved so that
was that wasn't leading right i want to
yes i want to go back to the iranian
revolution of 1979 this is a little bit
before my time was born in 79 but i mean
they had this guy the shaw and it was
like this this 2000 year old monarchy
and they basically i think the cia
caused this revolution this to this
theocratic uh what's this the ayatollah
khamenei this this like now they're this
theocratic muslim
well theocracy country but we basically
created that yes we did
why i don't know to make enemies for
people in the region
but then then all of a sudden the world
became globalized and internet and now
yeah specifically the soviet union is
this like like the soviet union falls
and now the us is like okay time to
clean up the mess we made is that what
they've been doing well i mean that was
1979 the iranian revolution but after
the soviet union falls i don't know
about cleaning up the mess but it's like
expand the footprint grow the empire
more bombs more wars more money
expand them remember this is all tied at
the same time to neo uh
economics which is like blow out all the
markets free trade let's engage with
china let's engage with the every eu
let's create the free trade area of the
americas which was all just about
globalized globalized globalized
so it all adds up and stacks up into the
globalization
theory this whole thing
that we're basically me and my friends
and maybe you guys are on board now i
don't know
are anti-globalization and all these
things that we're talking about are
globalization about the globalization of
american empire globalization of
american trade american values american
freedoms american all the things what's
the issue you have with globalization
like what are some bad bad things say
about it well i mean look the great
example is what we're just talking about
here with afghanistan is that we believe
that we have a set of values and customs
and morals and a virtuous framework that
we can go and just apply universally to
civilizations across the world does not
work
people are different
and they don't want what we are selling
right you have to occupy for for i don't
think three generations i think four
generations okay yeah either country or
in their mind enough to have all of the
people who remember the old ways pass on
dead and then the next generation
remembers nothing and says this is the
way things are they've always been right
right so that's why that's one element
the second element of globalization
that's no good for everybody is the the
race to the bottom on wages and
environmental standards which is what
the with and i'm throwing environmental
standards in as sort of a joke but that
was the argument against the 1999 wto
ascension of china into the world trade
organization of which black bloc the
precursor to american antifa was
protesting well black black bloc was
just a tactic right antifa uses the
black block tactics so it was it was ant
it was leftist activists using the black
bloc tactics same as antifa in
opposition to world to the world trade
right and their arguments were actually
organizations were actually pretty
salient
we'll have a global downward pressure on
wages we'll have a global downward
pressure on environmental standards and
what happened all that [ __ ] all that
stuff went to china and they you know
their environmental standards are much
lower wages when exported all around the
place and what happened our entire
middle class and industrial uh you know
support within the united states has
been completely hollowed out and
offshored so like globalization
the fundamental problem with
globalization is that our cultural way
of life is unique to us as a people
it is not a universally applicable to
every civilization and person around the
world and that is a hubris and arrogance
that we have to get over but that's and
you're right and that's what a lot of
these dictators and conquerors all
believed
at every single one of these
authoritarian dictatorships who are
expanding and taking over thought this
universal set of values the set of
values we have is universal and can be
applied the thing about the the
communists that's different from us and
to a certain degree is that they were
like we'll just kill anybody who opposes
us yeah the u.s does that to a certain
degree to a certain degree but they
genuinely try to buy people
it's the capitalist approach just give
them money and comforts it's really
amazing you give them something to lose
whereas the communists were like we'll
just lose them right
well what's interesting too about
communism is that it's like sub-nation
state it's like below the level of
nation-state it's a way to unite various
factions and people in different nations
against the nation state that they're
living in which was what the end of the
west valiant era and the west valley
treaty was supposed to be about which is
supposed to be about like
nations here not meddling with their
ethnic group and there in that nation
and like setting up these boundaries so
that the conflicts were actually between
nations but then communism came along
and made it so that people across
different nations and boundaries could
unite around a common cause and become a
common faction because a common problem
now that's not you know totally
notwithstanding all the issues around
communism but that is one of the
interesting conflicts it presents with
the nation-state system as we have it
now i think one of the things that we
have to appreciate as americans
is that our american way of life our
values our virtues our constitutional
republic our representational government
all these things they're not universally
applicable
not everyone in the world wants it not
everyone in the world needs it not
everyone in the world is going to thrive
under it
it is specific to us in our context and
our geography and our history and our
language and our religion and our people
and that's why it works for us it's our
thing you know you know what i
absolutely loved this i i i there are
many things i've done in my life and
there are many things that i've
experienced on my this is amazing going
to taksim square in istanbul and
istiklao amazing because i'll tell you
this so you've got toxic square
obviously the riots and the tear gas was
certainly experienced i wouldn't call it
a net positive you know people giving
you like lemon juice to like wipe off
the tear gas i don't know if that works
just made it hurt more but anyway so
that was an experience but no no no no
no no no no no no no no no you was
brilliant when the conflict wasn't
happening here i am in this in this
beautiful park with people doing their
thing and there are these really old
like several hundred year old uh baklava
shops and you go in and they have all
these different kinds of of baklava it's
amazing so delicious and they would give
you these little things of ice cream
with it and that was something i never
got anywhere i've had baklava in the
united states not the same by my no
stretch i was there for a couple weeks
and i was gaining weight i was like this
stuff is too good it's just drenched in
sugar syrup and the desserts they have
they take like grain and they twist it
and spiral it and then pour syrup on it
and that was something unique and that
experience and i love that walking down
it's the call this this is the cloud
this long street uh this long street
i'll tell you my problem with
globalization
i had that experience and the oh man and
the isla burgers you know that means wet
hamburger they take the burger they like
dip it in like they get all moist we got
to make these things like lamb and then
it's like they put this sauce on it and
then they steam it and then they wrap it
so it gets soggy and it's like a buck
and you're all drunk in the middle of
the night and you walk in and they just
take it out of the heater and give it to
you and everyone's just eating them
amazing what an experience and i tell
people like you haven't you ever have
like the islam burger and people like
whoa what's that it's this unique thing
i went to uh the bahamas
get off the cruise ship and i'm thinking
this is going to be so much fun to bask
in the culture that is the bahamas and
you know what i saw mcdonald's
mcdonald's starbucks gucci hard rock
cafe and i was like
this stuff's next door to me i don't
want to go to the bahamas for this so i
had to walk into some neighborhoods and
try and find a local shop where they
were making local food and i was like
that's the problem it's going to be like
everybody put on your grade jumps jump
jumpsuit shave your head everything's
the same no matter where you go anywhere
in the world it's mcdonald's and
starbucks welcome to globalization it
strips out the adventure and the
uniqueness and the decentralization of
the human experience agreed and in fact
we call that global homogenization
and that's something that we think is
really bad and so therefore i am in
favor of global homophobia that's what
i'm in favor of it
homogenous yes exactly my problem with
globalization is we had a guest on this
actually made this point i think or you
did about someone else that said it is
that it's inevitable it's going to
happen regardless it is how is it going
to be actually not inevitable at the
rate we're going the expansion and
interactivity
the point is that i think that it might
be inevitable but how it's going to
happen is is not is is variable so what
there's been a push back against
political globalization people don't
want that people don't want that in the
u.s the internet people are terrified of
a one-world government so they're going
the economic route they're trying that's
what's more cultural it's a cultural
like with the movies and the music and
the film and the jeans and the whiteness
and all the things those things are
exported you can export them across the
pipes you can uh you know the the
internet pipes and the satellites and
the whole thing that's everywhere have
you ever been and dude i have been to
third world countries in backwater
villages up the creek down the way where
there's like nothing else but you know
what you could get
you get three things you can get a pack
of marlboros you get a coca-cola you get
a johnny walker you get those anywhere
johnny walker oh yeah johnny walker
johnny was all poisonous i tell you this
man when uh
you know the being in in egypt during
the revolution you see the mcdonald's
three blocks away yeah but that's that's
decades old that's been that's been
everywhere mcdonald's has been in
beijing since you know who knows how
long ago but the most important salient
factor in what we're talking about here
is the values
the political values the personal values
the morals the virtues the family
structure all these things that we hold
dear the virtues that the country was
built upon
i just spent some time studying with the
claremont boys out there in las vegas at
the fellowship okay one of the things
that we really was struck by when i'm
reading original texts original text
from the founders john j alexander
hamilton all these guys not only just
the around the federalists and the
constitution but around state
constitutions and the discussions around
state constitutions right so you get
real context it's not just the federal
thing it's in every state from everybody
and they all firmly believe the couple
of following facts one that you have to
build the government like a coat to suit
the individual
okay it has to be specific to the people
two that the american people were a
unique set of people bound by language
culture history stories experiences
blood race religion and so forth and so
therefore that the american government
was built as a coat to suit these unique
people
and we can't take that coat
tim imagine if we took my jacket and put
it on you i'd be really warm you'd be
really warm and you'd be swimming and
you'd be half lost in that thing right i
could probably make a pitch pitch a tent
put a stick up and then just sit under
pitch a tent he said get a little fire
going so if you gave me your jacket i
put it on i put it on my flex and i bust
the seams out like the hulk it's the
disaster but it looks cool
so so this is what our country was
founded this is not just like one guy's
idea this was the entirety of the people
founding our country understood that our
people were unique our history was
unique our language and religion and
culture were unique and the government
that we built was unique for those
people
so this idea that we can take what we
have here for us a special kind of
people
and like just universally apply it
across the world is asinine well what
about bitcoin
i mean i think that we're we've
universally spread a concept
globally where we're globalizing under a
currency yeah but that's just the idea
of money exists everywhere commerce
exists everywhere exactly on earth but
you know i'll put i'll put this away
i'm 50 50. i think there needs to be
strong international ties but there
needs to be sovereign respect so what i
mean to say is
is there something is there something we
can do to make sure that a country's
borders
laws and customs are respected
and
we prevent war we prevent major serious
international conflict and destruction
and havana syndrome or nuclear weapons
you know what's funny is that the wars
that we have been involved in are
because we want to exert our way of life
on other people
i'll tell you here's the problem it's
utopian the idea yes i think i think
globalization
is very very likely and the issue is
there are people
who are willing to die for their
ideology or seriously harm others and
they're people who aren't and you know
the united states is a bunch of
hyper individualistic
uh um you know right-wing nut jobs in
the middle of the woods with a bunch of
guns and i mean that in the best way
possible i mean like we got a whole
bunch of people who are sitting on a
pound on a mound of beans with guns and
be like i'm not gonna bother you don't
bother me and i'm like right on brother
yes so it's very hard to conquer
that's not everybody though there are a
lot of countries where they're like you
know my god is the one true god
therefore and they're gonna they're
gonna fight and they're gonna attack and
then you have communists who have found
subversion to be the powerful method and
so now you might have that hyper
individualistic dude who's you know
living in the in the mountains who's
minding his own business respectfully
peacefully and he's well prepared but
all around him the cities are falling to
subversive ideologies to to submit to
break apart the d we we have a
relatively decentralized system here
compared to many other places
yeah but by design and so you can
subvert that
and that's what what communists and
marxists and others have been doing so
ultimately what i see is those who are
willing to oppress lie cheat and steal
have a major advantage and they've been
winning in that front
and that's because
the difference between what we have here
and what they have there
at least at the time of the founding and
for most of american existence was that
the american citizenry was devout
christian
okay and so this is the fundamental
issue
is that
our declaration of independence is based
on natural law and natural rights which
come from
the creator
and in the christian belief the creator
is a monotheistic god so there's only
one god
and if you've got other gods you're
wrong
so we have one god natural law natural
rights american constitutional republic
that's the direct lineage and the
declaration of independence and that's
what everybody at the time thought when
they signed the thing
and so if you believe at the same time
that there's only one god and that
everybody else's god is wrong well then
there's almost a compulsion to spread
that ideology to other people but i
think that we we need to do is just
respect the fact that other people have
different ideas and i interviewed
alexander dugan the russian philosopher
who pushes his his ethnic
multi-polarity ideas
because he believes that people are
different based on their geography and
their location and their history and who
they are inside etc and that they evolve
into needing different political regimes
people have evolved to need different
political regimes
the giant the chinese for example have
evolved in their own civilization in
their own context with their own
everything
so they've evolved their own political
regime just like we have here in the
west but population growth will lead to
borders pressing on borders there's no
free land anymore for the most part
there's like some rock like volcanic
rock i was looking at down by antarctica
that's like an unclaimed thing trying to
find unclaimed land here it doesn't
exist you can build islands
sure sure but the point is that we've
reached it it used to be like okay it's
no big deal because there were a lot of
places that were just open send them to
the colonies
yeah and and they're ill-defined
territories so people who are like
people with claims remember when there
was just like claims on land well we
claimed this and we claimed that no now
there's nations everywhere i have a
weakness
so now what happens when china says we
need to expand and as we expand we need
more resources and we can't get access
to resource x because it's not within
our borders let's go ask them for it
what would you want we'll not give you
anything for this resource but we have
to have it otherwise our people are
suffering when a population of any
species grows too large and the amount
of resources levels out
everyone suffers you see it in every
every overpopulated species deer pigs
turkeys whatever they become sickly they
become malnourished and they fight
become aggressive because there's just
enough resources to sustain their
current level of population so then what
do you think is going to happen to
people when in a country like china with
1.4 billion they're like we got to get
food somehow we're importing it from
australia what happens when these other
countries start saying we're not going
to give it to you well we're not going
to sit here and die and now that there's
no unclaimed land someone's gonna have
to give up what they did claim well we
bring up an interesting point which is
that every other country around the
world shares the perspective that i am
putting forth right now which is that
there is no universal morality no
universal virtue no universal political
regime no universal constitution that
should be applied no universal rights
none of it no one else believes that
except for us well there is a universal
thing as economics it it nominates
everything a bank a bank can can cut
your your account they can they can
remove you if you want to talk about
disrupting the decentralized union of
the united states yeah communism but
banking
they can hear what you're saying i heard
you're saying can we just finish this
one thought before we get on to that
which is to say that the chinese people
aren't looking at their chinese
government being like everybody here
needs to be chinese all around the world
we're going to export chinese ideology
everywhere no they're thinking
mercantilist right and that's one thing
that we haven't woken up to is the fact
that china is mercantilist their
national trade policy is to enhance
their national
uh standing and their the good the good
uh benefit to their people okay that's
why they do trade which is to make their
nation stronger as a nation for foreign
policy and national domestic policy
issues but they're not out there trying
to say everybody needs to be chinese
communist party no they're like we want
that food we're going to go get it which
is a totally different perspective than
what we have which is like we have to
end tyranny all around yeah but
that idea of any terrorist propaganda it
was it was a way to sell war to people
because we want to extract it it's
definitely not it's a hundred percent
not it goes all the way back to woodrow
wilson
it goes back um
they conquered in the name of defense i
i will i will say at least in america it
goes back to woodrow wilson and the
initiation of the progressive policy and
modernity and scientific method and the
improvement of everything can be reduced
we can eliminate evil we can eliminate
disease it's reflected in the covent
zero policies that people have
especially in australia and what's in in
america as well it's this idea that we
can perfect things perfect things
perfect things so if there's evil out
there we can perfect it but i
i disagree we did not get involved in
syria because we wanted to bring freedom
and bashar al-assad was an evil dictator
it's because for a long time we've been
trying to build a pipeline the cutter
the qatar turkey pipeline and syria said
we will not
go against the wishes of our ally russia
who says no to this because they want
more control through through gazprom etc
etc and so then true back in 2009 the
guardian reported this a couple years
later that the u.s said we will have
ground troops in syria soon with the
next few years and then surprise
surprise when as soon as there's an
opportunity for the u.s to get involved
and give weapons it's it's it's
interesting you're pointing out
competing factions you're pulling the
competing factors let me say something
interesting
in the american revolution the french
says the french say we're at war with
the british hey these colonists are
going to help us let's supply them with
arms and then it worked and the
americans get independence in syria the
u.s sees this uprising and they're like
and depending on who you ask by the way
because the the leftists will say it was
a cia conspiracy from the get-go but
they see this opportunity with this
uprising and they're like we should arm
some of these people
because we don't like bashar al-assad so
they intervene to provide resources to
the competing faction hoping that once
it topples we'll be able to build that
pipeline nothing to do with freedom
everything to do with opportunistic oil
pipeline building i agree i agree with
that i think what you're pointing out
are competing factions within the united
states foreign policy apparatus you're
pointing out factions where people have
like monetary
monetary excuse me monetary interest at
heart but at the same time there is this
progressive ideology in our foreign
policy in our domestic policy that's
reflected in the gender policy and the
marxist policy and the feminist policy
and the critical race theory policy
which is all about like perfecting
things and making perfect through
science and the scientific method and
like eradicating evil and spreading
freedom and all the great things that we
have all around the country did you see
the report from project veritas oh about
the the teacher the teacher in
california he's got mao we got mao on
his wall i have 180 days to turn these
kids into revolutionaries yeah uh
i think it's one of veritas's most
important stories to be honest and and
it's like it's like some random dopey
dude but this is important because you
know a lot of us are familiar with the
goings-on of google because everyone's
got their complaints the left says oh
it's a monopoly that won't ban hate
speech and everyone's kind of focused on
them and complaining and it's the
censorship stuff's overt
but we keep hearing these stories about
children being indoctrinated and they
say oh that's not happening it's not
happening veritas then finds just one
one guy one little old teacher who comes
out and says here's my auntie for flag
here's my mao poster and i i tell kids
they're bad people that they disagree
with me and then they move further left
every single year and you're like these
people are real
and what you don't realize is the one
guy they caught like a cockroach you see
one of the wall yet that means there's a
thousand more behind it so for veritas
to expose the one guy is just the
beginning there there needs to be more
exposure to this but man i i tweeted
this out somewhat jokingly
your twitter's all jokes
it mostly is but i said imagine hating
your kids so much you sent them to
college right because like what what
happens to your kids when you center
these institutionalized learning
facilities
they shave their heads and you know put
on weird
rotted clothes so i i'm dealing with
that right now my daughter is 16 years
old she's looking at colleges she's a
very successful active junior straight
a's varsity athlete can go any college
she wants to in in the country
and she wants to go to some pretty
powerful university she wants to be a
doctor which is like one of the things
that you can't do without without doing
the thing unfortunately i think you
should be able to test into that you
should be but you can't right now like
if you want to be a stock trader a tech
guy a programmer a coder a businessman a
philosopher historian whatever you don't
have to go to college to do that but but
to be a doctor you got to do that so so
i have and i would do this ordinarily
but i am just prophylactically like just
blasting her with as much information as
i can so by the time she does get there
that she will at least have a baseline
for to deal with this in doctrine
indoctrination have you taught her about
compound interest
we haven't talked about compound
interest just yet but i certainly will
do that right after this call but on the
topic of the sick with the antifa guy
and the project veritas thing you're
absolutely right that is just the lowest
hanging fruit that they were able to
scoop up into and to identify there have
been reports all across the country
we've got the woman
making the kids swear uh pledge
allegiance to the queer flag in their
classroom pledge allegiance to the
queers she says this is on tick-tock
it's been widely disseminated it's not
me being hateful or anything
there is very clear evidence where
people say well you know what it doesn't
matter that the kids lost learning time
and can read more poorly today compared
to last year because we taught them what
a riot was we taught them what an
insurrection was we taught them what you
know white systems of oppression are so
all these people again this goes back to
exactly what the problem is in
afghanistan aside from the competing
military monetary interests is that the
attention of our education apparatus is
focused on the wrong thing
the attention of our education apparatus
is focused on making these kids into
little revolutionaries that pledge
allegiance to the queer flag that don't
care about reading and math but they
only care about learning about rioting
and insurrections and that is what is
happening so therefore every other
console every other result is is is
negative because the primary attention
is put on the wrong
thing it's rot yes it is
it is institutional rot it is the core
foundations that make up the country and
our culture are rotting and decaying and
no one no well they're being poisoned
they're not just rotting into big
decaying they're being poisoned they're
being deliberately sabotaged
right we have saboteurs among us that
teacher is a saboteur right okay public
people argue with me but go back to the
source documents folks the public
education system in america was
established to to create a sense of
patriotism in america
this teacher is being fired this has
been this was the latest update we have
post millennial uh auntie of a teacher
set to be fired by school after
attempting to radicalize children
attempting apparently he's been doing it
for years wow but i'll tell you about
did you look but did you see the t-shirt
he was wearing when they confronted him
oh when veritas did what was it it was a
freaking sickle
that's a tattoo dude he was wearing this
he's got a tattoo in her chest bro yeah
it's right there he's got a tattoo on
his chest so uh the institutional rod
let me let me tell you a story so we uh
we at timcast.com are hiring a bunch of
fierce and independent journalists best
10 bucks i spend every month we're doing
a great job and uh we had a story
about a a truck full of modern vaccines
crashing
and there was limited for information on
it and we you know we thought it was a
big deal and so tim cast reporters start
investigating to figure out what's going
on with this truck
and it's a crazy story so i tweeted like
you know we ended up learning from the
local emergency response in west
virginia where this happened that the
dod took over and and the locals were
not allowed to give statements to the
press
and i said wow
now the truth is the department of
defense works with the hhs and they have
jurisdiction over vaccine shipments so
when it happened they're like hey we're
going to be handling this
so it's not like there was a grand
conspiracy or anything and i didn't i
never said that i tweeted out something
bad happened
truck crashes carrying modern vaccine
air space gets shut down hazmat comes
out now the dod is taking over
and i guess a lot of people
immediately assume conspiracies and what
ends up happening is an article gets
written claiming
that i'm a conspiracy theorist that i
didn't accurately inform any of my
followers about what really happened
even though i posted a link to the story
now it's something i want to get off my
chest and just mention because it was it
was like an example of something
affecting me but i also think it's a
good example of institutional rut that
there is someone who knows my story was
100 true 100 factual and i never implied
there was a grand conspiracy i genuinely
was like whoa a vaccine truck flipped
over this crazy the dod's on it isn't
that crazy we were worried like
did they lose a shipment of vaccines
because they weren't telling us and then
we got a statement saying don't worry we
were able to recover all the vaccines
like oh okay i wasn't implying that like
aliens were coming or any crazy stuff
but someone had to write about it and
they had to twist it and frame it such a
ridiculous and absurd way
that people who will read that will have
their minds warped
that is just one example i experienced
recently but i'm sure everybody knows
the examples of how the media lies
cheats and manipulates like shinzo abe
and trump when he throws the fish food
in they fake it or the very fine people
hoax and so what's happening now and the
reason why i think you see
these schools focusing on the wrong
thing
is it's
the whole system of our institutions has
been twisted and corrupted by an every
you know by by the most absurd and
extreme hyper individualism
there's no national unity there's no
sense of community there's no scruples
this writer at this at this news outlet
didn't say to himself i can't write that
that's not true he went how can i twist
this in the worst way possible to get
some clicks because i don't care about
what happens to this country i don't
care what happens to my community i
don't care what happens to the people
these these schools bring these people
in and and these principals and these in
these superintendents the ones who
haven't been truly indoctrinated are
like i'm not going to stick my neck out
when this teacher does this stuff
because why should i put myself on the
line for the sake of the future of this
country our children and what ends up
happening then is over a decade of this
happening eventually the people running
institutions are in the cult and their
their minds are warped and twisted and
then they seek out more of it the way i
view this problem the easiest way to
understand it is to look up the youtube
video of hitler with a woman's body
doing tai chi with the incredible hulk
where nursery rhymes are being sang
because this video exemplifies the
broken fractured algorithmic dystopia
that we're living in these videos were
going viral people were making them
because the algorithm was feeding them
to babies that is something so we as
adults can see that video and say this
is insanity why are children being fed
this video babies can't understand that
because they have no frame of reference
they just see this and that's life for
the rest of us spending 10 years going
through the broken media ecosystem the
lies the fake news and the algorithmic
manipulation
we can't tell
adults who who live in it are the same
as the babies being born into it
we can see the one thing because it's so
crazy we can't see the crazy in front of
us now obviously i think people watching
the show people like us are initiated
and what i mean by that is we're
discerning we see something and say i
want to challenge that and i want to see
how that how that stands up to scrutiny
then you look at all these people who
who all of a sudden are i tell you this
man you know breaks my heart is the
hacker community going woke
full-on authoritarian dogma and i'm like
hackers were anti-establishment
totally like agnostic and now the whole
it's just becoming more and more woke
and i'm seeing people say here's what
you have to say here's what you can't
say and i'm like we're changing the
words of code and it's just they don't
understand they're living in this
fractured rotted and broken collapsing
system they can't see through it i agree
i agree 100 on everything you said
especially that that really uh very
descriptive phrase that you use the
algorithmic dystopia right
but there's a deeper fundamental issue
here it goes even farther back than that
and i just started to get into it a
second ago about education
when the founders created this country
they realized that liberty did not mean
the freedom to do whatever you wanted
it meant the freedom to do what you
should do
what you ought to do to do the right
thing and so they thought okay we're
going to give people freedom so at the
same time we also need to teach them
what they ought to do
john adams very clearly said that this
constitutional republic that we have is
only suited for highly virtuous moral
and religious people they also said at
the same time across every colony in
every state constitution and in the
federal papers and in the letters of all
the founders they said we need to
establish public schools in order to
teach patriotism virtue morality in
order to create a people
suitable for the government that we have
created
fast forward to where we are today the
education system today when you try to
think that it should teach patriotism or
love of country you would get laughed
out of the freaking room right or the
idea that the people can just come in
and teach communism and marxism and
anti-american hate and crt and 1619
stuff in our public schools or the idea
that we're going to be a nation made up
of a majority of atheists
i am not a christian i have been
baptized i'm very sympathetic and i'm
very interested and i'm reading the
bible and i understand its value but at
the time of the founding they didn't
even conceive of the possibility of a
widespread atheism
so the country has been created
in a way that required this that and the
other guard rail
institution education morality religion
and they have all been wiped out and so
what we're left with now is a
constitution that that that promotes not
just liberty to do what you ought but
freedom for licentiousness
easiest way i think for people to
understand this is just to reference the
replicators in in stargate sg1 when sg-1
created the disruptor device the
replicators of course the humanoid
replicators were made up of nanobots and
the disruptor device severed the
communication between each nanobot
within the greater replicator causing it
to disintegrate into a pile of metal
shards basically so uh i'm i'm half
kidding understanding it's probably very
esoteric and i've been watching a lot of
stargate lately but the point is
macgyver's imagine you have the founding
of this country it was a bunch of
different colonies that didn't much get
along in a lot of ways but right i
didn't know they fought a lot right and
had their own current had their own
currencies and then the constitution
came about after the fact because there
were a lot of issues and a lot of smart
people came together and said yo let's
compromise and figure this out together
and boy was that was that really amazing
and then a shared story started to
emerge and all of the different states
eventually fought each other because
they were about to break apart
then there was
the the famous line from national
treasure a truly a great philosophical
uh piece with a nicholas cage where he
said before the civil before the civil
war people would say the united states
are and after the civil war they would
say the united states is i don't know if
that's true or not but it's a good it's
a good way to understand that after this
point or at some point people started to
view each and every state as together
and fighting for the common good and the
same goals and someone from new york
would be like ah those you know those
country folk but we're rallied together
around a lot of common ideas yeah now we
are very much like those nanobots being
stripped apart yes there is the the the
individuals no longer are forming a
greater community
no social cohesion okay we have no
social cohesion and up until the 1960s
and 70s it was very easy to maintain
national cohesion because you had just a
handful of people giving you the stories
that you were supposed to listen to and
believe you had walter cronkite sitting
up there basically at a pulpit preaching
to the entire country telling people
what to think what to believe what the
feel what stories to venerate what
heroes to have what myths to entertain
and then now with technology
and we're we're as guilty of a
participant of anybody
is that instead of one guy telling
everybody what to think and creating
social cohesion that way
we've got a million people talking to a
million people with a million different
stories and now we have no social
culture
because of it and it's it's tv stats a
big part of the static is if if people
were all telling real things it would be
a lot easier but it's the misinformation
that's sewn in that's causing massive
dissension and confusion but it's just
trust me but it's not to say that up
until the internet that there wasn't
disinformation there was plenty of it
it's just that we all suffered it at the
same time so it created our own
own social cohesion in that way right
right the newspaper would have to be
vetted people would say okay this we're
double checking this we're double
checking this everything but then of
course it'll be like and there's weapons
of mass destruction in iraq right so
they lied all the time and i think the
reality for people is they just woke up
to how bad the lies were yes you know
there were there was a report i was in
uh in kiev during the uh euro my dance
stuff oh this is a new story for me tim
that's right and uh i was on the ground
with vice and we were reporting on a
protest when i think it was channel 4 in
the uk put out a story where this woman
was narrating what was going on and she
was incorrect and so i tweeted hey you
guys are incorrect we're here on the
ground reporting for vice this is what's
really happening and they basically just
said
so
they didn't care that what they reported
was fake they just don't care
there you see there are some people
that have a yearning to understand and
share the stories they they've they've
learned to share the information
and to just inform the real journalists
are like here's what happened do what
you will with it but we also have a lot
of people who are just like it's a job i
don't know they wanted me to read the
script i don't care what it says it just
keeps making me think that better of
this term better men a lot of times when
you come around jack because these the
founding fathers talked about a better
men would take care would run the
country basically and i feel like we're
born plebes and if our parents are
better men we have the opportunity to be
fast-tracked to become a better man but
otherwise we just grow up as plebes the
internet obviously you can study and
research but like is it real that
there's like a tiny tiny group of co
like cogent critical thinking better men
and that everyone else is just dumb
animals nope kinda
like are we are we here's a question to
live in this here's a question for you
guys because i know you can transcend
those what's
what is more where are you more likely
to find virtue in one man in a few men
or in all men
one ah so you're a monarchist i think
that if you have a crowd of 100 people
well that's a that's a hard question to
answer because there's a lot of ways to
answer it so this is the fundamental
political philosophical question right
the odds that a bunch of people have the
same virtue is not as likely not the
same there there there's no difference
of virtues there's only virtue there's
seven virtues right right there's virtue
there's seven there's charity there's
diligence there's courage honor i don't
think are these the catholic virtues
you're talking about oh there's
different ones there's ones that you can
there's spiritual ones and then there's
ones that you can do in like sort of
practical world right
what's the right answer to that question
well it depends whatever your answer
that question is is the form of
government that you think is appropriate
if we thought if we thought that there
was virtue most likely to be found in
the masses then you would just go with a
straight democracy but not even the
founders of our country thought that
they thought that the people would lead
to tyranny they were they were right
they're right democracy doesn't work so
you don't equate so we've ruled out
democracy now we're down to
representative maybe republicanism and
we maybe we can go to like uh
aristocracy oligarchy or we can go to
monarch i think it's a much more
sustainable to have a group of virtuous
people than have one
founding father
with a tortuous document founding father
smart fellows yeah they they put a power
on the paper well they're like you know
should we have a monarchy just like you
know a king and they're like but then
there are these problems okay what about
like a council of elders what about
these problems how about direct
democracy well then you get this how
about we do all three and they all yell
at each other and they're like that's
actually pretty clever you know right
and they i mean it's very complicated
when you layer on top especially the way
that it was back then it's a little less
complicated now because you actually
vote for the senators or whatever but
like the senators were supposed to be
the house of lords they were right they
were supposed to be like the landed
aristocracy the oligarchy kind of it was
that you would vote for local
representatives who would then appoint a
senator to go and represent your state
to the federal government and actually
think that was better yeah because it
wasn't that they were the house of lords
like in the uk you're just a lord and
you know you're you're you're you know
then they have religious people who are
appointed as well it was that
i
you know i'm sitting here in my little
town and jack murphy says vote for me
for state representative
and i'll make sure we get a good senator
go to the federal government i'm like
make sense to me and then people paid
attention to the local level by changing
the senate elections i think the 17th
amendment is at 17th by changing it to a
popular vote in the state now
people stopped caring about their local
elections they slowly began to stop
caring about local issues
they started you know oh i'll vote for
this guy he'll take care of it and now
you get the insane phenomenon of people
running for congress going if you vote
for me for congress i'm going to clean
up this town no you're not you're going
to the federal government you're going
to vote on wars and stuff you're not
gonna say you're moving to georgetown
buddy yeah what are you talking about
did you hear aoc talking to that group
of people like five people or something
like what are you gonna do for me it was
like a month old but it was just really
grating to see how she's been
separated from those people for now for
a while they're sent to washington to do
washington things they don't act well i
would be much happier actually if the
congressional representatives from state
districts went to congress and worried
about federal issues
the problem is that they go to congress
and they they they bring federal money
back to their local district that's the
actual problem it's supposed to be
that
you you operate on the local level yeah
and it's and it it slowly moves up and
fed when you vote for someone for
congress someone running for congress
should be like if you vote for me i'll
vote to end wars
i'll vote for lower taxes or things like
that or stronger borders for this
country instead they're like i'll make
sure that the homeless problem in our
state or in our town i'll bring that
northrop grumman factory here to our
state and i'll get that federal program
and that federal thing and that but
let's
never get out of committee and then
nancy pelosi comes in and says you're
just impeaching trump and they go okay
pelosi but let's go back to the first
question which is
where are you most likely to find a
virtuous man or woman
and i can hear curtis yarvin in my in my
ear telling me that we just need a
monarchy or a caesar a monk temple a
monk temple
men above time this is a this is if you
want to google that go for it but men
above time are people that are separated
and distant from the current daily
goings-ons
and who can live a life of of of
contemplation
and philosophy and politics and you know
there is some there is some value to
that and you know when you're distracted
with the day-to-day material urges of
the world it's hard to be uh able to
you know philosophize in such a way
that's best for everyone without your
own personal stuff getting in the way
honestly i don't think any man can be
virtuous by nature i think we're all
corrupt and prone to corruption we all
need to eat we all need to destroy life
to consume it to survive like that's
nastily corrupt from the beginning
that's why they say humans are dirty
humans are sinful by nature nature well
it's it's destructive it's it's it's
vile it's considered evil to the
creature being destroyed you know i
suppose
it's terrifying to have to eviscerate an
animal and drink its blood to survive
but that's not a predator if you're not
a predator it's not terrifying it's a
perfectly most natural but we are
predators no you see ian i think it's
because you've been insulated you live
in a bubble we all have i've been i've
been eating the flesh of the animals
that i never saw killed exactly exactly
so there's a lot of people who grow up
in the countryside when they're little
kids their dad hands them a gun and says
you know point it down keep your finger
off the trigger and we're gonna go hunt
some turkeys
and then they watch it happen by that's
by nature we're hunters killers you know
yes
i remember watching this old science
video where it shows talking about
evolution and it was talking about like
plankton and plant cellular life and
then it was like and then one cell
attacked another and it absorbed it and
i was like and that was the beginning of
prediction and stuff like that and i'm
just like
yo i mean it's kind of crazy that there
are plants right chilling minding their
own business just doing their thing
they're like i'm gonna grow right here
because this is where i am and then they
grow and they're like i get my energy
from the from the carbon from the air
and the and the light from the sun and
i'm just minding my own business
building my own chemical structure and
then along comes some some chicken
and the chicken walks up and just goes
around rips it off
that that's so violent and that poor
innocent plant well yeah that's life
right are we gonna sit here and be like
animals should stop eating plants
because plants didn't do anything to
anybody or we're gonna be like we you
know eat plants and we eat animals right
that is life so knowing that then we
have to decide who's going to be in
charge is it going to be a human because
they're vicious and they're hunters and
their killers and they need to survive
they need to kill to eat do you want
that person lording over you and your
family yes because they understand how i
survived thank you very much but they
don't even know who you are in this
country that's the problem this is the
problem it used to i think you know i
think as you said the family is
communist right or you were quoting
somebody yeah i was quoting uh to lab on
that right it's it's a really great idea
to say that at the smallest levels yes
leftism is perfect and then as you scale
up it just makes no sense as it gets
bigger and bigger it's idealistic it's
utopian and it'd be fantastic but once
you have different you know cities that
have different interests and different
needs there's going to be conflict
because people don't want to die so i'll
put it this way you hear these stories
about you know a shark attacking a
swimmer and they're usually like either
the shark was confused or desperate
there was a uh you know we had daniel
turner here and he was talking about how
the the foxes have been going after his
chickens and he was like normally they
won't do it now they are and i'm like
they're getting desperate the foxes
don't want to go near your house they're
scared of your house but when they have
nothing left to lose they have to make
they have to do something humans have
similar
situations where our country says we
have low food stores we have low energy
we have low of this material that we
need for our people we're getting
desperate what do we do and if they
can't get it from anybody else war
breaks out just like animals fighting
i i agree with that resource competition
has been a driver of conflict for a long
time but in the united states the the
conflict driver is our factions and our
different factions come from our
different faculties inside the united
states inside the united states yeah i i
so ideology is i think for the most part
unique to the to to humans although we
have seen tribal warfare among uh some
lower primates or i i don't know higher
primates like you know apes yeah they
fought each other and now chimpanzees
and that might be a very very rudiment
rudimentary ideology but i don't think
comes close to what ideology actually is
meant to represent humans are literally
going to be standing there and someone's
going to be like
i think marx was right and then someone
else is going to be like you're nuts and
then he's going to pull out you know his
his you know stone but even before we
get to competing ideologies within our
own ideological system there is inherent
competition based on the varying
faculties of men and by that i mean
each individual man has different
capabilities different interests
different uh ways that they can get
things accomplished in the world and so
therefore they're going to have rooted
interest in their faculties and because
we have different iqs and different
capabilities and people are taller and
shorter and stronger more inclined to
economics or real estate or agriculture
or whatever
as those people gain power then their
interests become factions and those
factions become competitive within the
united states and that's one of the
reasons why madison wanted us to have
such a wide-ranging expanse of a
republic so that there wouldn't be a
dominant faction within the united
states but then
woodrow wilson basically legalized the
faction of rockefeller and jp morgan
federal reserve military industrial
complex they built the school system
like that's basically a faction don't
say the school system again the school
system was founded at the time of the
founding for the purpose of creating
patriotic
you're saying the foreign were created
to indoctrinate kids yes in american
love of america
allegiance but from what i've learned
and i've never gone through and that's
not what you you i i you i tell my
friends so i can say this but you say
that's so smugly to irritate me because
you're making a point it's sarcasm
it's sarcasm i'm trying to irritate you
i'm trying to you're trying to flip the
perspective on what it means right but
you're saying like oh it's to
indoctrinate kids into loving america i
know you're just making a point but like
yes that's exactly the point john and we
need that in 1903
rockefeller
the reason i bring this up is that
you know i've been mentioning a lot that
principle isn't necessarily the issue
it's it's it's often the subject or this
or the specific ideology and that's why
you might see a lot of people who are
immediately called hypocrites if you say
the indoctrination in schools is bad and
then you're like well the schools are
supposed to indoctrinate people but
towards what i want and then they say
well the school should indoctrinate
people towards what i want correct and
that's where the clash happens you're
both fighting over the ideology culture
crash in 1903 rockefeller founded the
general education board which provided
major funding for schools across the
country and so basically this his
faction
okay okay okay but that's 140 years
after or even more than that after the
establishment of public schools for the
purpose of creating patriotic citizens
yeah we're familiar with virtues and
republican government yeah well i guess
it's more about he amalgamated his no he
still um he stole it he's like get ring
when the bell rings you get up you have
to go to class or you'll be penalized
like show up sure take the test
um
on top of the whole like moral thing
this is a good that's a good distinction
because i make this argument on twitter
often then people are like no i was
industrial people and they wanted to
train you to work in factories and
whatever whatever fine that may have
happened later but public schools are
designed to build patriots that function
well in our patriotic system
period they wanted it they wanted social
cohesion yes when the kids because this
government needs i'm sorry this kid this
government needs a particular kind of
person well so this is what happens when
you have 13 colonies and they don't
really agree with each other a lot other
than independence and they need to stay
they're saying to themselves we need to
plant a tree whose shade we know we will
never sit beneath
that is raise our children to understand
the values that we have set forth and
why it's a good thing and everyone
growing up should understand what you
know blood and treasure was sacrificed
for this independence oh man you
mentioned blood and treasure
holy cow
if we
abraham lincoln said that if you violate
the law you disrespect the blood shed by
your forefathers i don't agree with that
not all laws are good
law does not equal versus the
constitution let's say okay he didn't
say that though right he didn't be
violent
he he specifically was talking about
just law in general and love of country
he was a lawyer and he did have to do
that he had to become an autocrat to
keep the union keep the union yeah but
the point is is that
we here right now are having this
conversation because people that came
before us sacrificed their lives their
sons their treasure their wives their
family their homes all of it
and to disrespect the law that they
created the country that they created
after that is to disrespect them
and that is what his foundation of
political religion was which was the
idea that he had that he wanted to
animate the country with political
religion
a love of country a love of the
constitution a respect for the people
that died for it
because as time goes on you forget
he made address to this thing called the
lyceum
i want to say it was around like 1830 or
1840 and at that time he identified the
fact that it had been sufficient enough
time that all of the actual founding
fathers were dead and all the
revolutionaries were dead and all the
guys who lost sons and families and
fathers they were all dead so by 1840
1850 nobody remembered the fact that all
these people died for what we've got
i saw an interesting tweet from michael
malus man we shot this guy out who is
michael mouse
he's a writer really funny guy but it's
just really good and uh
it was it was it was an ad
an idea he tweeted out and then i just
elaborate elaborated upon that
by by mere a virtue of your existence
proves that victory is not only possible
but that it's already happened before
yeah it seems like that oh and
and so that's something
yeah and basing it off of what he was
tweeting and what i mean by that is
there's been so much evil in this world
the rise of communism the dictators the
the murderers the nazis the fascists and
here we sit today
doing a show about american values
freedom and liberty which proves not
only have we won in the past but here we
are able to continue this which means
victory is not only possible but it
already happened we constantly do things
that are challenging and hard like i i
tweeted out i think yesterday if you
only ever did what was easy for you you
would you just laid there you never
would have gotten you would have laid
there until you died like we always
struggling to learn how to do something
new and to change our environment that's
ultimately what we're tools for i love
this quote it's like of course the
shortcut is hard if it was easy it would
just be the way
you know what i mean so it's like
everything we're doing if we're doing
the easiest thing imaginable it's it's
it's
it's not challenging it's just the
normal
but for all of us that are fighting for
something that believe in something that
are challenging something of course it's
hard
it has to be but but
definitely possible that's the point uh
impossible i'm saying yeah these things
that seem insurmountable i think it's
because we're looking at big picture a
lot of times like crt and everyone's
like i don't know where do you even
begin but when you break it down to like
the local level and then you see like
teachers union or a group of teachers
are revolting or this guy's getting
removed this this teacher is getting
removed for good thing to see that that
guy wearing the sickle who's got the
antifa and the black lives matter and
all that communist stuff who says he's
got 180 days to turn the kids into
revolutionaries he's getting fired
the woman that said pledge allegiance to
the queers she's getting fired pressure
okay so offensive statement it is very
offensive to everybody to everybody and
anyone and you know it look uh standing
for the pledge of allegiance in school
right now is not super cool depending on
where you live my son told me a story
about he's literally the only one in his
class who stands every morning recites
the pledge wow everyone else i was the
only kid not doing that when i was
little right because that was kind of
the cool thing to do but you know what
now the rebellious thing to do is to
stand up and say i pledge allegiance to
the flag of the united states and to the
republic for which it stands one nation
divided is
and on the constitution your rights are
from god i'm like that's just why are
you weirded out by it it's literally in
the declaration of independence upon
which this government was founded
because i think well we talked about
this before i wish we were here when we
had the first time that our rights are
just we just earned them through warfare
we took them by forces no they're given
to you by god that's what they some
magic thing they wrote in there to be
like and if anyone ever messes with you
just say you can never and it's like no
this didn't exist before you created it
of american freedom we talked about this
you don't understand what right means
the government infringing upon your
rights doesn't mean you don't have
rights it means the government is
infringing upon them
yeah i i think the idea that you have a
right to anything in this reality is is
absurd are you are you born with the
right to defend yourself
i mean i have i'm born with the ability
no no well technically no because you're
a baby with no abilities you just label
that's an ability but not a right i have
no rights as a as a small infant you
have no right perceive yourself
nature with no government around you and
there's people there's people around you
and you're all around you does anybody
would anybody look at you and say to you
sir that you don't have the right to
defend yourself
well i mean if uh if i've done something
wrong i'm no the answer is no i think in
a society that word right might not even
exist don't even use the word society
just imagine a bunch of dudes in anarchy
yeah they would they would probably
fight but would they look at you and be
like you have the right to defend
yourself no i don't think that word
would even enter that alexacon into a
mind of barbarians
so ian if you're staying in the middle
of the woods
and some guy runs up screaming with a
pointy stick would you just go oh well
guess i'll die i'm not saying because
these things might i'm not saying that
they they're not good things these ideas
are great all right but the fact that
they're given from god okay what was
your question again if you're standing
in the middle of the woods and a guy's
running at you screaming with a stick
would you go i have no idea i would jiu
jitsu his ass and put my knee on
you have no right to do it i have to
answer your question however i want good
you have a right to do that you have no
right to do that no neither of us have a
right we just do have a right to do that
no one knows i have the ability it's not
a right what is this right what does it
even mean
what what what what do you mean
you bro you're making semantic well
nothing i'm being very literal um right
legal rights no we're not talking about
legal rights we're talking about natural
rights natural rights natural like in
other countries they aren't natural
that's the point well it's because
they're also not monotheistic some of
their pagans some are different but that
doesn't mean they're wrong it just means
it's a different view of what is natural
in order to live
you must defend yourself
if you can't live
then you don't exist
you have a right to defend yourself
that's the first most fundamental right
that you have a right is a legal social
or ethical principle of freedom or
entitlement ethical rights are
fundamental normative rules about what
is allowed of people or owed to people
according to some legal system social
convention or ethical theory rights are
of essential importance in such
disciplines as law and ethics especially
theories of justice and deontology
they're different everywhere
every country is different every ethic
or
ethical form so we're back to our
original discussion which is that
monotheistic
gods gave us natural law and natural
rights which gave us the united states
of america that's why it's not
universally applicable because there's
other countries around the world and
other places other people that don't
have the same perception of god and it's
it's
it's really simple again ian you're
confusing infringement with existence of
rights
you plea clarify that please you're
arguing that because someone with power
would suppress your rights your rights
don't exist that's not true
no no
if you're if you are captured in war
yeah okay you can physically defend
yourself from your capture captors even
though they will beat you and try and
stop you and they will take they will
tie your hands behind your back and
continue beating you and you can still
resist you have a right no you have the
ability to do it doesn't give you the
right that doesn't exist in a pow camp
yes it literally there are no rights in
a pow camp yes there are you're just
there you don't understand what a right
is you're confusing if you're like
you're violating my human right my basic
human they're like what who is this what
is this thing and they're beating you so
again you're talking about the
infringement of rights versus the
existence they don't understand that
person doesn't doesn't it doesn't exist
to them so it's like for you to say
because i believe it it it's real for
you too even though you don't understand
now if you attack the the the the
soldier keeping you there will he defend
himself likely but he has no right to do
that no but he has the ability to and
probably should preserve his own skin
of course he has the right to defend
himself he has the i mean okay now we're
just talking about rights and abilities
i'm talking rights are legal things you
do this all the time you make semantics
you just said that rights are legal
things no natural natural legal social
or ethical assumptions natural rights
come from natural law which comes from
god and you do this a lot when you lose
an argument you make a semantic change
to the art i don't think there's going
to be a win or a loser to this we're
just talking about it but rights
literally do exist there's like the
golden rule and there's there are
certain rules that transcend all
civilizations
the golden rule only works in certain
types of civilizations like
it doesn't work if everyone's cheating
so there are bad people there are good
people they're an infringement
infringement of rights and rights exist
regardless of whether someone tries to
suppress them i don't i don't agree with
that i think that rights only exist
because we tell ourselves they exist
so
you actually have a point but i wanted
to read to you a little bit about
natural law because natural law is an
idea in sorry it's a theory in ethics
and philosophy that says that human
beings possess intrinsic values that
govern our reasoning and behavior and
this is something that is understood to
exist in almost every single human
civilization these are overarching ideas
this is like the understanding that
murder is wrong it's like the
understanding that marriage is a
societal good not true in every society
but commonly understood in most of them
so this ties directly into the idea of
rights as being something understood
governed by natural law so you should
look at like natural rights as they grow
out of natural law it's something that
is over most society not strictly uh
like we use in our judeo-christian
society here i think i think exactly
i think jack put it well about
what you need to be able to do in order
to survive and function which is a
natural natural right they've
essentially codified that into a
structure that's kind of the ten
commandments is what he was doing like
these if you follow these you'll
probably survive for a long time and so
were lost will our species and so then
the americans were like okay let's make
a government out of that and tell
everyone these are like uncorruptable
parts of you and that's if we believe
that then they become on it
but only because the government by gun
forces is commanding that is that able
to exist if you're in the middle of the
woods and you're buck naked you can
speak freely you can move freely you can
defend yourself no one can stop you yeah
but there's no law though there's no
there's that there's no rights in this
bro the law is to restrict the
government not people how many times we
have to say that
you mean the bill of rights are the
constitution but all the laws in america
is to restrict well yes the bill of
rights the constitution the idea of
natural law whatever this is to restrict
the government
from infringing upon the rights that you
have innately that's what they tell you
that's my argument is that i don't think
innate i don't think people innately
have any right to anything we just we
were fortunate to be born into a society
where we so he's a total will-to-power
guy i mean if you were thrown if we were
thrown into the jungle alone naked
what the hell there is no natural right
what are you talking about we just
survived
yeah so you can defend yourself from
predators you can say well because i
have a right to it it's because what the
hell i'm doing it like in order to exist
as a human being you have to defend
yourself
yeah that's for real so ian that's what
we're talking about if you talk about
laws if you don't think the right exists
that means you would just lay down
whenever threatened no
the law calling it a law and saying it's
like
you just said if you don't think the law
exists i'm sorry if you don't think
rights exist then you would just lay
down and die whenever you're attacked by
a predator saying that defending
yourself
the act of defending yourself means that
you enacted a right i think is is
fallacy just because you defend yourself
doesn't mean you're enacting any kind of
human rights
yeah just because you're literally
exercising you're right when you defend
yourself no you're exerci you're
defending yourself you're not i mean in
the united states you would be
exercising in a country where you're not
allowed to defend yourself like north
korea we're done because you're just
arguing well we have yet to begin tim
because in north korea you don't have
the right to defend yourself you against
the north korean guy they just beat you
and infringe on your rights there's no
rights there they don't have rights you
don't have human rights so this is what
they're saying when they say that the
rights are given by god this means that
the government should not ever infringe
your right to defend yourself ever ever
ever this is what the founding fathers
the constitution says the government
can't do that
but other governments do that yeah but a
human being in any circumstance when
threatened has the right to defend
itself as does every other creature on
the planet when threatened just because
a bear can hold down the fox and the fox
is struggling doesn't mean the fox
doesn't have the right to defend itself
it doesn't have the right yeah you don't
know what the words mean
listener first-time caller here's ten
dollars you have your attention are you
telling me god gave you the power
yes you're saying god gave you the power
jack are you can defend yourself ian
yeah you think god did that there are
there are fundamental base truths that
we understand very simply and what i
mean is obviously we can get into the
nuance and complexities of how glass
shatters but typically when you throw a
rock in a window it breaks there's
nuance there i understand that typically
a bear when hungry will eat something to
to feed itself there are basic things we
understand to be true
there there are rules as to how they
define what life is and there are basic
functions as to how that life
propagates in fact there are some plants
that defend themselves because if you
have no right to self-defense meaning a
fundamental
entitlement
to your ability to stay alive then you
would cease to exist because your
lineage your dna would just collapse
meaning everything that exists today
exists because it had a right to
survival no that's not what we didn't
have rights before you know we invented
them
in the tide pool they didn't have rights
they didn't have a basic paramecium
rights they just survived the ones that
ate the food survived and the ones that
didn't didn't
so the point is arising from the fact
that everything that survived fought for
its survival we recognize a fundamental
naturally occurring entitlement existing
within life forms to try to stay alive
right no
circuit a natural entitlement to try to
survive this is what you do what are you
talking about a natural entitlement to
try to survive no you haven't because
you don't know what the word you have to
try to survive
you're not entitled to it because you
just see some things never change around
here
ian
because you're making it up and i just
read it to you well you just gave me
like a long three-part definition
firstly because
ian if you're not smart enough to know
words and i can't even read you the
definition how do we have a conversation
look everybody firstly everybody can
make mistakes you made a mistake earlier
when you you said a word that wasn't the
right word um and we're not we haven't
even yet to agree let me let me just i'm
gonna end this conversation very simply
jack and i say here's a right you say
rights don't exist i say okay ian let's
try and figure stop okay let's try and
figure out what rights means here's the
definition of a right and you say well
that's wrong and i refuse to accept okay
you don't want to be that's not what
happened and you you just told me of
rights don't exist
i said that the idea that god gives you
basic intrinsic rights is idiot it's
it's fantasy and that's why people are
erupting against it right now because
you don't know what the word means
a right it's a it's a fundamental
natural natural rights a fundamental
naturally occurring entitlement
intrinsic within life this is something
you just create this is literally just
read it too but you just said that it
had to do with ethics and some he was
ethics it said rights exist very
prominently within legal and ethical
theories another one ethical and social
issues and legal theories i think
this is some of the best whiskey i have
ever had
can i put this on the camera
look at this this rice ohichi rice
whiskey this is some of the best stuff
i've ever had thank you so much i
appreciate that i'm glad you're if you
really enjoyed all that smash the like
button subscribe because we're gonna
have a member segment coming up later
but we should read super chats because
we went long oh boy all right let's see
let's see where where are we at ian
making me crossland
you guys ready for an even more
contentious argument the lukewarm says
on one of your earlier segments you said
women shouldn't be forced by anyone to
carry another human being because of
their freedom not morality but doesn't
any parent have the obligation to stop
their child from dying in their care
yes the issue of pro-life versus
pro-choice is very very difficult and
there is no middle ground there's
literally none you're dealing with two
independent life forms that have
fundamental rights and the problem is
where does the government intervene but
i will say this the point i was making
is
i'm worried about setting precedent for
the government to decide when they're
allowed to intervene in someone's
medical decisions and when that person
is required to provide their own body to
someone else it's very very difficult to
parse this because there's a baby that's
alive that i believe life begins a
conception but i will just say something
very simple it's okay because if you're
pro-life we can actually have a
discussion on how we compromise on this
and i being pro-choice as cbs news
described it the left is pro-abortion no
joke cbs news said the pro-abortion
groups they're not talking about choice
they're talking about people who quite
literally say you have no right to
choose your own med your medication when
it comes to vaccine mandates but the
government should absolutely have an
open door on all abortions up until the
point of birth in some places
no joke in virginia for instance that's
where they were pushing that so if we're
going to sit here and discuss like okay
we think abortion is wrong but there's a
fundamental question of government
intervention okay that that i think we
can we can we can really disagree on but
then you have this other group that's so
far left i need binoculars to see him
saying outright you have no choice to
you have no
right to medical autonomy if the
government mandates you get medicated
you go and do it and shut up and by all
means terminate your pregnancy that's
not choice just pro abortion
heavy heavy heavy uh i have grown to
become pro-life over time i have been
presented well i'm not gonna say that
personal stuff uh let's just say uh i
came to understand that my personal
position was pro-life through experience
well so what is that what does that mean
right here's one of the biggest
challenges with the pro-life and
pro-choice stuff is
what does it mean it means it means
i hope my kids aren't watching
they are
it means that there were problems there
was a time in my life where that that
came up as as as an option
and in my heart said absolutely not no
way
period
and i've come to understand that you
know it's separate dna it's a separate
human it's a beating heart man
do you think it's a human before it has
a brain how can it be not a human if
it's got dna and a beating heart and it
evolves into life it is a human being in
a various stage of development that's it
i am changing every day
the fetus changes the zygote changes
it's all on the same continuum from
conception into death so this is what i
said and that's what we lost uh in the
argument
there was a time where the the left was
or the liberals in this country were
safe legal and rare it's between the
person and their doctor the government
shouldn't be intervening and i'm like i
understand all that and i grew up with
democrat families saying you know
abortion's really a truly despicable and
awful thing the problem is there are
certain circumstances that are
humiliating embarrassing life-altering
and a doctor and the mother might have
to make that very difficult choice but
of course my dad would say abortion just
because for no reason just no that's
absolutely wrong it shouldn't be done
that way and so that's where
chicago democrat was you know
now i find myself much more closer to
what's considered pro-life only because
you can call it close relatively to the
pro-abortion crowd who come out on their
tv shows yelling everybody get abortions
and they wear shirts celebrating it they
they you know they lena dunham saying
she wished she had one that is a whole
level of depravity she lit she said she
wished she had one even though she
doesn't have any kids yeah let me let me
she wishes she just had gone through the
experience of having an abortion yeah
disgusting look while you're bringing
that up let me just point out the fact
that feminism.com okay lena dunham said
she wishes she had an abortion
just want to make sure we have that
clear for as little as like a kink
because they're pro-abortion they just
want it and so i'm i'm like so here's
what i say like
as i just described how i grew up
reviewing it
i think there's a confusion as to what
it means to be pro-life versus
pro-choice because there's no real
pro-choice movement anymore you have
pro-abortion people and you have
pro-life people right and the pro-choice
people safe legal and rare my issue is
there are circumstances in which the
baby could die
is dead is seriously you know is at
serious risk that could put the mother
at risk there are many many medical
complications and they may be rare in
which case i'm like man i don't want the
government like to file paperwork on
this stuff and give my private medical
history and man having the government
involved in that the problem though is
that i recognize 99 point whatever of
abortions are listed as no reason at all
meaning they're typically just
contraception which is abhorrent
so two two points one feminists in the
60s clearly stated that they wanted to
destroy the concept of maternity
they clearly stated they want to destroy
the concept of motherhood
they clearly say they want to destroy
the concept of family
okay so that's baked into this ideology
it's destroy the concept of motherhood
second
i saw just today a doctor a pro-abortion
doctor
say oh my god guys we have to react
here's what we have to do now that
there's this crazy abortion law in texas
here's what you have to do you have to
one
get on contraceptive right away iuds
condoms birth control pill use all of
them get on contraception right away
second get pregnancy tests and test
yourself regularly third track your your
your period whatever whatever
and
in her clear explanation of all the
things that you should do
it became obvious to me
that her ilk and her people and the
people she was talking to were clearly
using abortion as contraception
because she hadn't been saying all along
get on a contraception get an iud use
the birth control pill and use a condom
and pregnancy test yourself all the time
as a way and not only like hey let's
maybe not have sex with everybody
but the idea was she had to replace the
contraceptive tool of abortion
with contraception all right that's
absurd how how it it's a crazy idea that
someone would would rather go to a
clinic for abortion than just use birth
control or a condom or something just
get an iud i mean look i don't i don't
want to promote promiscuity amongst our
young people but there is some valid
validity to the argument that like every
kid should be given an iud and an hpv
vacs at age 14. exactly
let's read some more super chats we got
camel of the mojave he says
just remember if you're about to cough
in public you need to fart to hide the
sound so they don't send out a warrant
for your arrest
i have a question for this for this
gentleman i have a question for this
gentleman if i'm wearing a mask on a
plane and i have to sneeze
do i pull down the mask and sneeze into
my napkin or do i sneeze into my mask
and live with that for the rest of the
flight
you take the mask back you aim up and
you go
into the air request the stewardess
first i think you gotta you gotta pull
it up and sneeze on the napkin that's
awesome otherwise that's just like viral
load yeah all right soleil cucumber lime
says
i'm against impeachment biden is an even
better advertisement for republicans
than the black lives matter riots and
defund the police true i got money from
government to pay myself and i bought
hex crypto which is uh congratulations
this is not financial advice no but i
try you know i don't like it when people
are like trying to pump their crypto but
the first part of that was good nice
that's uh that that's what i said well
people super chat being like hey tim
this is the best crypto buy the crypto
now because i think they're trying to
pump it yeah but uh it's a good point i
mentioned earlier like maybe republicans
just want to sit back and let biden keep
slipping on banana peels because it's
going to make the 202 2022 midterms just
it's true but it does make them look
feckless okay it makes them look weak it
makes them look uh impotent
okay and tens of thousands of humans are
left behind in afghanistan because of
him too indeed indeed but it's like i
mean look kamala harris is impeachment
proof miss
impeachment immunity
for joe biden
anything joe biden's doing now would be
made worse by a harris presidency i
don't think so
i don't think i think he's he's unfit
but dangerous but he's unfit through his
mental incapacity as well as his
ideology she is mental she's unfit
because she's a psychopath yeah she's
authoritarian i think psychopath too
though
they're both bad you know you know he's
a psychopath in the sense that he's not
rooted in any moral system if you listen
to the things that he said in the 60s
70s 80s 90s whatever that dude was a
straight up and down racist yeah i guess
no question about it like i don't want
my kids in a racial jungle
was his statement against
integration in the schools yeah he's a
bad person he's a bad person and you
know what's interesting though is i will
listen to him in the 80s in the 90s and
i'll be like he's a bad guy but he's
kind of witty
he was sharp he was he was like he was
he was obviously present
he is so obviously not present
now oh yeah yeah and most other things
all fake news 2020 right 2024 should be
if they just look well i guess it
depends on if they rerun him right are
they gonna rerun him are they gonna are
they going to primary a sitting
president
that is like for real though right
so if they re-run if they re-run him in
2024 it should be the the easiest
victory that's ever been had
i think even if it's kamala it'll be
the cake walker oh that's good that's
exciting
that's exciting if we can get there
if we can get there as a nation all
right let's read some more we got krep
ck he says tim can i get a shout out uh
a channel shout out i made some great
jalapeno mango jam recently you said you
won't eat food that is sent in but what
if it was made on video we don't always
agree but i respect that you try and
cover the facts i i don't people send us
food i don't eat it like i like
what just give it to ian
i used to eat it
will change no i will we get a lot of
food sent to us i bet people will be
alive well so there's local businesses
and i'm like you can't really expect me
to eat something i got in the mail you
know what i mean random yeah like i
don't know where this is what this is or
where it came from probably know someone
gonna get a dump in a box and be like
it's chocolate and i'm not going
anywhere near it right i think we should
i think you should hire some interns and
let the interns test it and then we can
all try this delicious jalapeno ham also
i i never open boxes the same way either
how come oh in case there's something
jumps out later like a snake or
something weird stuff in it you know you
never know we got we got security
protocols we take operational security
very seriously
to the next level since i've been gone
by the way in the last six or eight
weeks this is a very important one
there's forums and documentaries real
creative ways of opening boxes like
swing it down on a rope and it like hits
the
there's a letter and like cuts it open
just just perfectly the side so that we
can see what's inside yes all right john
kristen says glad to have the real jack
back instead of that knock off poso guy
oh snap that's one of my shots my very
very good friends jack we just had a
wonderful weekend with him and his wife
at the will chamberlain's wedding with
jordan lancaster we had a great time out
there in the smoky mountains i love jack
pacific would love to do a jack and jack
yes a jack and jack episode here when
can we get that yeah we can make that
figure out jack you can ride with me
here we go until we get to the border
the sheriff's after me for what i never
okay matrix says tim titan hunter or
warlock i'm partial to my hunter but the
titans in destiny have the best butts
the first character i made was a warlock
because i thought the warlocks were
hunters and then i leveled up a warlock
and i was like i guess i'm playing the
warlock and then i was like i gotta make
a hunter cause hunters are better
because hunters can be invisible so oh
can they in the game i used to play a
hunter could heal himself in the field
that was always really good and come up
with some rations in the field that was
always a big deal yeah they do massive
damage from the titans titan was my
least favorite to be honest uh hunter is
the best because they have the you know
they have the stealth and i play rogue
in warcraft as well but i i like the
support functions of the warlock and
destiny if anybody out there played a
game called tele arena
send me a dm on twitter that was the
best game ever
ever
you're in a cave nathan o'connell says
tim i told you about the sailor that
burnt down that ship there have been two
bomb threats on the uss nimitz in the
last three days could be contractors
sailors or government workers all with a
security clearance morale in the
military at all-time lows jeez yup
here's one william martin says hey gang
have you ever heard of the battle of
athens in tennessee a certain bearded
scottish count made a video about it
it's an amazing tale of election
fortification and second amendment
uh famous you guys know the story i've
heard of it i don't know this guys came
back from world war ii
they've uh they found that corrupt local
officials had seized government and they
took the
city over and had a new election they
fixed it
legitimized it and then after that it
was just just kept going they didn't
like send in the feds or anything to
break it up
i don't remember
scrots mcgoat says tim you are now on
the wrong side of the e4 mafia why i
said they probably know more about this
than we do i was complimenting them
scrote's my goats wayne kerr is there a
mr wayne
here eileen dover
i love don
key dick
don
key dick
this is a great video they're talking
about dover you guys got to see it's on
twitter i don't know if it's real i
think it is real
it struck me someone got like a council
member to give him a bunch of [ __ ]
simpsons he's bart simpson this council
member
it's still funny because you know
i'm mature all right
isaiah schlavola says yo what's the
email for account problems every time i
log in the site immediately logs me out
members at timcast.com
and
there yeah i think it's a database thing
which we i should be fixed for most
people but
happens from time to time yeah look you
know we actually have a really excellent
development team they're like some of
the best and the site i think is
fantastic but
man bugs happen i guess
i
we try our best
when you build a tech company you have
like a five to one support to that's
right it's a fountain so we have people
that literally just sit there waiting
for emails to come in are constantly
answering them of course if it's like
midnight people are asleep you know but
maybe we'll hire some you know some late
night people to just sit at the emails
and make sure we get everybody on time i
think that's a good idea
all right ronan jack says unfortunately
i believe biden should be kept in hear
me out everyone who didn't vote or voted
for him need their eyes held up and take
in the horrors and learn their lesson
the right will not be there to shield
them from themselves
that's a good point
do it
omg puppy says the shah of iran was a
constitutional monarch and he legally
disbanded the parliament when they
elected a communist prime minister there
is a counter narrative to cia plot and
both are probably true wow
you get your answers yeah don't let a
good uh problem go to waste they'll
swoop in and get what they can out of it
all right brown bear 992 says tim you
said the only way the withdrawal could
have been worse as if we bombed a bunch
of civilians that's exactly what they
did and droned a bunch of kids on the
way out just a few days ago i know yep i
meant like if they decided to escalate
the war with the taliban and just start
bombing cities like relentlessly in this
instance they were going after isis and
they're talking about working with the
taliban so you know yeah bad
very bad
all right
michael calavoda says it seems this
falls into the great reset do you agree
or disagree what do you think is the
next domino
i have no idea um i'll tell you this
over the past month
i've been going to the supermarket
because i need cream for my coffee oh
yeah and i use real cream i don't use
any of that bogus half and half garbage
or you know i do have the international
delight stuff you just a little bit
uh it hasn't been there
store's been out wow of all of it
and that's weird it's like local farm
town yeah but it's like a supermarket so
i'm like i guess we gotta go to a local
farm like they can find dairy farm and
find some cream because they don't have
it they have the fake stuff they have
cheese gross yeah i'm not the cheese the
fake stuff yeah yeah i like the real
stuff i've been doing i've been doing uh
keto actually a lot of a lot of fat a
lot of avocados and whipped cream and i
take your vitamins oh it's so good for
you burn that sugar yeah this guy's
statement that it might be part of the
the great reset i wonder i wonder if
this whole military industrial complex
is part of that
is aaron up says hey tim i pitched my
woo to sydney today and i like my odds
wish me luck i'll keep you and lydia
posted yes there you go you can do it
good luck
all right pitching woo that's a silly
term mike sullivan says great seeing
jack back
i noticed there is a jump to say bush
went to iraq because of his father's
history with them in february 93
multiple iraqis tried to topple the
world trade center with a car bomb also
the attack on the uss uss cole was
tracked back to
i don't know what that word is because
we have a filter thing for websites
hmm assad oh maybe no i don't know
turn it i don't know where they really i
don't think they're really trying to top
all the trade centers with that bomb
well they they put the truck up to the
center column
so yeah oh wow in the basement they went
to center ride
the world trade center was definitely
like an attraction point for terror
multiple times yeah it's like a symbol
of capitalism in a lot of ways
all right adam horage says conservatives
understand individualism and group
demonstrations they don't recognize both
need to be used to change institutions
and we need to start with universities
somebody tweeted at me that i won't
criticize conservatives or whatever and
i'm like i mean i guess it depends on
what you mean because trump supporters
aren't the same as like the neocons
which i rag on all the time like mitch
mcconnell lindsey graham are awful but
you know everybody on the right makes
one of them but it's also like dude
when a pro-lifer conservative comes to
me and says i'm pro-life and here's why
i go oh i understand those arguments
they make sense i disagree on some
ethical issues here's where i disagree
the left comes out and says we're for
choice they're taking away the choice of
women and i'm like yeah new york you
mean with the vaccines no no no that
we're okay with and then i'm like so
you're not actually arguing anything to
me you're just basically saying give me
power when i want power correct what am
i supposed to criticize the the right
for disagreeing with me i'm not
criticizing someone having a different
opinion we just disagree that's the
problem i face with them when they're
like choice except for that one they
don't want choice they're pro-abortion
that's why it's the most frustrating
thing to argue with any of these people
because they have no principle
there's no
principle tap dancing on quicksand
exactly
camel of the mojave back again says
society doesn't run off of virtue it
runs off of self-interest you ignore
basic human nature it's why communism
fails it's why individual individualists
need others it's why absolutists have to
accept dealing with people with
different morals interesting
and it's why we're having so much
problems here even though we have a
constitution that says that we shouldn't
be
all right
nevermoor says yo uh tim you mentioned
you played destiny a few times if you i
want to raid i'm down to help you know i
haven't really i i used to play way more
like uh adam and i used to play all the
time we wasted way way too much time
playing destiny man vaulted glass was so
much fun i love what you could throw the
solar grenade and then make him walk off
the edge because the game was busted and
they fixed it took away all the fun but
uh you know i played the latest one a
little bit and i've done a few missions
so far yeah we'll see destiny 2 yeah
destiny 2.
it is it is a well-made game you the
problem with it is it's a really really
good first person shooter the class
system i think they've really worked it
it's really it's a great system the
balance between the different types pvp
is fun but man is the story just like
written by a seven-year-old interesting
it's like a seven-year-old who wanted to
make star wars and so they wrote up this
like really trash fan fiction of star
wars have you seen that show on hbo
mythic quest
no is it good or maybe it's on apple
yeah it's about a it's about a game
development company and it's about the
guy that develops the game it's one of
the guys from always sunny
oh very cool
it's real it's super high quality it's
very high quality it's really fun and
interesting to see the back side of like
game development and there's like the
head of monetization they're like we
developed a shovel and how are we gonna
make money off the shovel i mean it's
just really interesting to see how the
games get made and sausage mythic it
looks like a lot of them uh charlie
day's involved rob yeah nick and elite
and he's the leader it's super funny
it's super funny and a good good show
all right let's see theodore
uh abate is that he pronounced it or
abate abbot ian natural law can best be
explained by socrates versus henry david
thoreau i encourage you to read their
arguments i think you're mistaken on
this issue but i appreciate your honesty
thanks i saw their debate on youtube the
other day was lit socrates and thoreau
if we could have we could do that
somehow do you think that we can like
reanimate jesus and like
debate einstein read the books no it's
not the same yeah that's like a lot of
work they engage in the same questions
over time this is the beauty of
philosophy the books have like no no
they're like hold on okay
the beauty of philosophy is that the
questions have been the same since the
beginning of time
and if you can get yourself up to speed
on what all the other thinkers have
thought you can engage in the same
conversation that's been going on for
3000 years i noticed you've been delving
into the bible it seems like you've the
bible the ancients the aristotle
plato
i've been reading all of it
very deeply and it's it's changed a lot
of the ways that i see the world
mason whaling says so frustrating listen
to y'all pump the same mid-2000s edgy
teenager anti-war talking points it's
much more intricate than you think read
more signed a lowly e4 remember the 13.
absolutely remember 13. uh yeah for your
service and i disagree i don't think we
have edgy teenage anti-war talking
points i think they're fundamentally
ethical questions that we ask ourselves
about why we go into these countries at
all and i'll tell you this we've
absolutely entertained all of the nuance
here we've had people on the show who
talk about how we need to maintain some
force to prevent the country from
falling into a complete disaster it's a
mess that we created that we're
responsible for and i look at what's
happening in afghanistan and i'm like it
really is said that they're very there
could have been stability there could
have been stores and happiness and some
values that that we do like
but we are not afghanistan
it's not about edgy teenage talking
points it's about being an adult and
saying you're supposed to be responsible
for yourself
you're not supposed to aggress on on
other people and you're supposed to mind
your own business and there's also the
fundamental understanding of china's
expansion other countries expanding why
we want to occupy the strategic location
in the first place what it would lead to
if we leave but there's there's one big
issue i think here
i've often talked about you know in 2016
for instance i said if you like the
status quo vote for hillary clinton
you'll get all the exact same stuff the
war the conflict the crisis the market
manipulations all that if you want
change then you gotta i guess vote for
trump because he's something not totally
crazy and for me i didn't vote
but the issue is
i guess it's utilitarianism versus
deontological thinking or this there's
probably some other moral moral issues
here the people who are like i'm willing
to violate the rights of others for some
justifiable ends
but there is no end there's never an end
we aren't going to reach the end goal of
like defeating china and say okay the
mission's over and uh we can all sit
back and just rest easy now that we've
won because there's never going to be a
conflict no there's always going to be
conflict you know which which which i
can give you a really easy example how
to understand this it's like a tv show
name any tv show where there's like a
protagonist an antagonist and then when
they finally overcome and defeat the
antagonist a new villain emerges oh just
by coincidence you know like in stargate
for instance they defeat the goa old and
then also the ori show up you can use
any show for instance where new villains
arise so there's always a power vacuum
there's always conflict do we decide
that we are going to have the ends
justify the means
and then do really really awful thing
oppressing people and causing war
conflict death hundreds of thousands of
civilian casualties because of some
nebulous and vague utopian ideal of what
we're supposed to accomplish i think no
we can't because the journey is where we
are
so we have to make the journey that's
what we're working on the edgy teenage
angst thing is like war's bad period
done
yeah bush bush is is hitler and you were
dumb and it's like my thing is like
imagine what we could have done with
that two trillion dollars if we put into
an alaska yeah you know we had we had
jack and daniel on and we were like
imagine if we occupied like nation
nation building in alaska our own our
own country we could have infrastructure
imagine if we bought bitcoin with two
trillion dollars in 2011 we'd be we'd
have like a trillion that wasn't able to
pay off our debt yeah there was the
market cap was like substantially less
than that
yeah imagine if instead of wasting money
being like we're going to colonize and
build another country to create a new
currency
could you imagine if they spent all that
money building a massive city in
alaska that made alaska actually have
industry and stuff like that it'd be so
cool they don't want to do it anyway my
friends smash that like button subscribe
to the channel smash it do it for ian do
it for jack do it for jeff do for me i
have a thing to promote may i promote
are we promoting let's uh go to
tapecast.com because the member
segment's coming up soon follow us at
timecast irl follow me at tim cast if
you'd like jack
we are doing a tour we're doing a
liminal order tour first of all if you
want to join the liminal order that's
liminal hyphen order dot com masculinity
brotherhood sovereignty second we're
doing a tour it's called the jacked
brunch tour we're going around to 10
cities across the country for food folks
and fun fellowship to break bread and
drink wine with people that see the
world the way that you do to give you
social connections to have fun so you
don't feel isolated and alone or like
you're crazy
come hang out with us follow me on
jackbrunch on twitter we've got an event
on sunday september 12th in chicago
tickets are available five star brunch
mimosa bar the whole thing sunday
afternoon after church that's your thing
come hang out we're doing it in chicago
and then new york two weeks later after
that on 9 26 and eight other cities
after that so act jack brunch on twitter
get your tickets come on down hey and
jack murphy live don't forget you can
subscribe to jack's oh that's right
youtube channel jack murphy live follow
me on twitter jack murphy live instagram
all the things your beard is looking
exceptionally awesome thank you very
much you know the red hen rochelle my uh
my fiancee she's a hairstylist oh she
trims it she's taking ownership of the
this is not die this is all natural i
ask people people are like do you dye
your beard i'm like if i did why would i
do it like this
why wouldn't i just dye it all brown or
all gray because never seen anything
like it me neither
did you want it when you were a kid no i
had no idea i didn't even know this was
here until one day i just grew it and it
just kept growing and boom and now i go
around the country and everybody looks
at me and they go
jack murphy live from temple look at
your beard look at your beard i can kind
of look down give me a mirror
hey i love you everyone thank you i love
you everyone too thank you jack i love
you bye and you guys so good to be here
oh yeah jack i'm delighted you're back
i'm so glad i was going to say i don't
know if you've heard but i am in the
process of getting more followers than
sour patch kids doing twitter do it you
guys need to follow me at sarah patch
lids so it's my only goal you've got to
be close right i'm getting close i'm
like 4 000 away oh nice we should be
able to do that right now lids lids not
kids that's right not the kids make sure
you smash the like button and head over
to timcast.com for that bonus member
segment and we'll see you all there
thanks for hanging out bye guys
you